SOME SUB COMMITTEE ONE ON
EDUCATION- IS CALLED TO ORDER.
AND SO A FEW OPENING
ANNOUNCEMENTS- IN RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUCH LIMIT. NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SENATORS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY IN THE CAPITAL.
WITH OUR WHOLE SENATORS ON THE
SUB COMMITTEE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM I'M JOINED BY
SENATORS MEN AND- CHAU VOGUE
THEREFORE NO NEED. AND THERE
WILL BE NO VOTES SO NO NEED FOR
A FORMAL ROLL CALL. OF THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE-
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED OTHER THAN IN THE
NORMAL ORDER OF PRESENTING
TESTIMONY AT THE BEGINNING OF
EACH ISSUE- YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE POLICE
SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH MID. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. AND I WILL NOT SIT
NOW. BUT TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6463.
648-442-9163 SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. 654-289-7654
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE THE TELECONFERENCES SYSTEM
AND HOW IT WORKS PLEASE REFER
TO THE SENATE PANDORA COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. ONCE AGAIN FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE TESTIFYING AS WELL
PLEASE NOTE FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTE. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIFETIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY CONTINUES OUR REGULAR
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING PROCESS
THIS IS THE THIRD OF EIGHT
HEARINGS. BY TO HEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
OTHER RELATED PROPOSALS WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION OF SUB
COMMITTEE. ONE THESE HEARINGS
HAVE BEEN MOVED UP THIS YEAR
DUE TO BOTH EARLY ACTION ITEMS
AND TO AIR ALL THE ISSUES AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE. AND WE WILL
TAKE FEEDBACK AND THEY ARE
LARGELY INFORMATIONAL AND IT'S
DESIGNED TO INFORM ACTIONS WILL
BE TAKEN LATER IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS IN APRIL OR
MAY. IN TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
RELATED TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AS WELL AS-
GETTING AN UPDATE ON THE STATE
OF SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN- DO EITHER
SENATORS MEN FOR A TROUBLED
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS. OUR
SENATOR MITCH. ART THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CHAIR LAYERED- SO I
AM A FATHER OF THREE KIDS WHO
ARE MY TWO OLDER TWO ARE IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MY YOUNGEST
IS ANTI GAY RIGHT NOW AND HE IS
BORDERLINE ON SPECTRUM SO WE'VE
HAD TO NAVIGATE THROUGH THE
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY'S
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS FOR THERAPY
HI THIS IS A PERSONAL ISSUE FOR
US AND WE KNOW THAT MANY
PARENTS FACE A LOT OF THE SAME
ISSUES. AROUND FINDING SPECIAL
EDUCATION- RESOURCES IN AND
THEY'RE OFTEN OVERLOOKED IN THE
STATE BUDGET SO I JUST WANT TO
PLOT THE GOVERNOR HERE- FOR
PRIORITIZING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
MENTAL HEALTH THESE ARE ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS-
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE EARLY
CHILDHOOD YEARS WHEN WE KNOW
THAT WHEN CHILDREN. REALLY
DEVELOPED IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT TIME IN CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND- JUST MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE EQUITY ACROSS
THE BOARD SO THAT THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAVE A FAIR SHOT AT
ACHIEVING- SO THANK YOU TO THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS OFFICE FOR
PRIORITIZING THESE I LOOK FOR
TO THE TESTIMONY. TODAY THANK
YOU THE FIRST- APPRECIATE THOSE
OF COM THERE REALLY HELPFUL.
AND I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THEY'RE JUST MEMBERS ACROSS THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THE WHOLE ISSUE OF. OF
SCHOOL CLOSURE AND EDUCATION
AND THEY HAVE INFORMED US AS
YOU JUST DID- ON THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES WITH THESE ISSUES.
WITH NO FURTHER ADO WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
IT SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
AND RESEARCH PROPOSALS- AND WE
WILL BE JOINED VIA ZOOM BY LIZ
MAY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AMY LEE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND ONLY
GARNER OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER AND WE WILL HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL ALL THREE WERE
DONE. SO LET ME WELCOME MY LIST
MAY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS LIST MY WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AUGMENTS ON GOING
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING BY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF EVIDENCE BASED
SERVICES. THAT DIRECTLY SUPPORT
THE SCHOOL READINESS OF INFANTS
TODDLERS AND PRESCHOOLERS WITH
A TARGETED FOCUS ON PROVIDING
SERVICES AN INCLUSIVE SETTINGS
AS PRACTICABLE. THE FUNDS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED BASED ON A
FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT'S NUMBER
PRESCHOOL CHILDREN WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND FUNDS
WILL BE RESTRICTED IN NATURE.
OF SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT THESE
FUNDS COULD BE USED FOR INCLUDE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES ONE
TIME PRORAMS ARE RESOURCES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS. STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES IDENTIFIED TO
THE TATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
INCLUDING INCLUSIVE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING. WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR PRESCHOOL CHILDREN
WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
EXPANSION OF INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR PRESCHOOL
EDUCATORS ON EVIDENCE BASED
STRATEGIES TO BUILD EDUCATOR
CAPACITY TO SERVE PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
AND MORE INCLUSIVE SETTINGS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ONE TIME FEDERAL ID AS FUNDS
FOR A STUDY THAT EXAMINES NON
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND AGENCY COSTS
AND PLACEMENT. THE STUDY WILL
INCLUDE A NATIONAL SCANNING
COMPARISON AND ANALYSIS OF OUT
OF STATE AND IN STATE
PLACEMENTS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND ANALYSIS OF
STUDENT OUTCOMES. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A WILL MOVE TO AMY
LEE FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AMY LEE WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THIS MORNING WE WANTED TO SHARE
OUR ASSESSMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE GOVERNOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
PROPOSAL I'M STARTING WITH OUR
ASSESSMENTS FIRST WE THINK
DEVELOPING A SEPARATE FUNDING
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY FOR
PRESCHOOL FURTHER COMPLICATES
HOW THE STATE FUNDS SPECIAL
EDUCATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOCATE
PRESCHOOL FUNDING TO A
DIFFERENT SET OF ENTITIES AND
USE A DIFFERENT ALLOCATION
FORMULA AND HOW THE STATE
PROVIDES THE REST OF THE K.
TWELVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AND WE THINK THIS ADDS
UNNECESSARY COMPLEXITY TO THE
FUNDING SYSTEM. THIS APPROACH
COULD ALSO MAKE REGIONAL
COORDINATION OF SERVICES
THROUGH SELFIES MORE
CHALLENGING ESPECIALLY SINCE
MANY SMALLER DISTRICTS
COORDINATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS WITH OTHER
DISTRICTS AND- SILVA. SECONDLY
BY PROVIDING ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR EACH
PRESCHOOLER WITH A DISABILITY
THIS PROPOSAL COULD CREATE A
NEW FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
OVER IDENTIFY CHILDREN FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN OTHER
WORDS EACH ADDITIONAL
PRESCHOOLER IDENTIFIED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WOULD
GENERATE MORE FUNDING. CONCERN
OVER OVER A GREAT INDICATION IS
WHY THE STATE FUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS IT CURRENTLY DOES
BASED ON OVERALL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE RECORD AND COUNTS OF
STUDENTS RECEIVING SPECIAL
EDUCATION ALTHOUGH THIS
PROPOSAL MIGHT ENCOURAGE
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AT A YOUNGER AGE.
ON THE LEGISLATURE WILL ALSO
WANT TO CONSIDER IN THE LONG
TERM EFFECTS OF CREATING SUCH A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE. THIRD
GIVEN THAT THE ACTIVITIES
FINANCE JUST MENTIONED ARE
INCLUDED IN INTENT LANGUAGE AND
ACTIVITIES THEMSELVES ARE
RATHER BROAD IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
DISTRICTS WOULD ULTIMATELY USE
THIS FUNDING WITHOUT CLEAR
SPENDING RESTRICTIONS OR
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE THE
IMPACT OF THE FUNDING. AND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH ADDITIONAL
STATE EFFORTS TO PROMOTE
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS INCLUSION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION MIGHT BE
WARRANTED IN THE FUTURE LASTLY
THE PROPOSAL DOESN'T ADDRESS
UNDERLYING CHALLENGES. TO
INCLUSION OR EARLY INTERVENTION
CALIFORNIA LIVE BEHIND IN.
PRESCHOOL CAN TO OTHERS. WE
SPOKE TO PRESCHOOL AS SPECIAL
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE MATCHING
CHALLENGES FINDING INCLUSIVE
SETTINGS IN PROGRAMS SUCH AS
FEDERAL HEAD START OR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. THIS WAS LARGELY DUE
TO PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS AND
REGULATIONS THAT MAKE COMEDY
EATING A CHILD WITH
DISABILITIES MORE CHALLENGING
PROGRAM STAFF ME ALSO IF YOU'RE
NOT PREPARED TO WORK WITH A
CHILD WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION DISTRICTS
MAY FACE CHALLENGES FINDING AND
IDENTIFYING PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
ESPECIALLY IF THEY DO NOT
ALREADY ATTEND A PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
EXPANDS THE EXISTING BASED
FORMULA TO INCLUDE PRESCHOOL
THIS APPROACH WOULD ALLOW TO
SEE TO RECOGNIZE LOCAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SERVING THIS
AGE GROUP WHILE AVOIDING SOME
OF THESE ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
INTRODUCED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
PRESCHOOL PROPOSAL. BECAUSE
PRESCHOOL ATTENDANCE IS NOT
CURRENTLY COLLECTED BY TO SEE
WE RECOMMEND DOUBLE COUNTING
KINDERGARTEN ATTENDANCE AS A
PROXY FOR PRESCHOOL ATTENDANCE.
ESTIMATE THAT THIS APPROACH
WOULD COST AROUND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR IT TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FREEING UP FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. WITH THE
REMAINING FUNDING RE RECOMMENDS
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER OTHER
MORE TARGETED APPROACHES TO
PROMOTING INCLUSION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. FOR INSTANCE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
EXPANDING EXISTING INITIATIVES
THAT PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON INCLUSION OR
SUPPORT COORDINATED EFFORTS FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION AND EARLY
IDENTIFICATION. BUT I'LL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BUT I WILL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT NOW WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC GARNER OF THE- STATE.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WELCOME.
THE MORNING THANK YOU ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE'S. PUBLIC
AND- THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION EARLY INTERVENTION
GRANT FUNDS. AND KNOWLEDGE IN
THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
INTERVENTION AND CREATED CLIPS
OF SUPPORTIVE HIGH QUALITY
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. REGARDING THE STUDY
TO EXAMINE NON PUBLIC SCHOOL
SPECIAL EDUCATION PLACEMENTS
THE CITY WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
CLARIFY THE EXPECTATIONS AROUND
THE DESIRED OUTCOMES OF THE
STUDY. AND REPORT TO ENSURE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ACHIEVE THEIR
DESIRED OBJECTIVES. WITH ME I
HAVE SERRA NETTLEMORGAN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL BRANCH AT
CD AND HEATHER CALUMNIES THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DIVISION
DIRECTOR THE ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. IN TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
ON THE L. A. O.'S PROPOSAL I'D
LIKE TO HAND IT TO HEATHER.
GREAT THANK YOU WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. HI THERE THIS IS
HEATHER CALUMNIES THE- STATE
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
FOR C. D. E. IN REGARDS TO THE
PROPOSAL AND THE- CHAU
EDUCATION- DEPARTMENT AND CD-
APPRECIATES THE- THE
MINISTRATION- RESTORING THE
FUNDING FOR THE EARLY
INTERVENTION GRANT- AND IT
REALLY IT KNOWLEDGE AND
IMPORTANCE OF. EARLY
INTERVENTION AND CREATING
INCLUSIVE SUPPORT HIGH QUALITY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS-
AS AS PROPOSED- THE FUNDING IS
UNRESTRICTED- AND THAT MAY BE
USED TO PROVIDE I THINK
CRITICAL. KIND OF CONTINUITY OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN AS WELL AS CHILDREN AT
RISK AND I THINK THAT'S- YOU
KNOW AN IMPORTANT NOTE TO
UNDERSCORE JUST IN TERMS OF- WE
KNOW THAT. EARLY INTERVENTION
AND EARLY DEDICATION IS
CRITICAL- FOR SUPPORTING EARLY
LEARNERS EARLY LEARNERS WITH
DISABILITIES- JUST A FEW POINTS
TO NOTE- IN REGARDING- THE- IN
TERMS OF JUST THE EXISTING
BASE. FORMULA JUST A SORT OF
FOOD FOR THOUGHT IN TERMS OF
REALLY- THAT THAT'S THE FUNDING
THROUGH THE EXISTING SPECIAL
EDUCATION BASED MAY DILUTE THE
PROGRAMMATIC AND POLICY
PRIORITIES HIGHLIGHTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- REALLY SO
IN IT OTHER WORDS ROLLING THIS
FUNDING INTO THE BASE COULD
COULD BE USED FOR ANY SORT OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION PURPOSE AND
NOT SPECIFICALLY FOR PRESCHOOL
SO- THAT THAT WOULD. NOT BE A
COMPLICATING FACTOR BUT IT JUST
WOULD BE AN EXTRA CONSIDERATION
FOR ELLIE AS AND AN ACCOUNTING
AND TRACKING PURPOSES AS WELL
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT THOSE
DOLLARS YOU GET TO PRESCHOOL
STUDENTS AS WELL- AND THEN IT
DEFINITELY THESE FUNDS WOULD.
THEN BE LIMITED ONLY SERVING
THOSE PRE SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND AGAIN- SORT OF
FURTHER RESTRICTING- THE-
ACCESSING THE POTENTIAL FOR
THOSE STUDENTS TO THAT ARE AT
RISK IDENTIFIED AT RISK FROM
RECEIVING THOSE FUNDS. I THINK
ONE OTHER SALIENT POINT TWO TWO
UNDERSCORES WHILE IS THAT- YOU
KNOW THE- MODIFYING THE BASE TO
DOUBLE COUNT KINDERGARTEN
ATTENDANCE- FOR PART FOR
PROVIDING PRESCHOOL FUNDING
WOULD RESULT IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
RECEIVING THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE- CHARTERS DO NOT SERVE
PRESCHOOL AGE STUDENTS. AND
FUNDING WAS ALLOCATED BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF PRESCHOOL AGE OF
THE DISABILITIES AND SO
CHARTERS DID NOT RECEIVE THAT
FUNDING IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY. HOWEVER
MODIFYING THE BASE. FORMULA ARE
CURRENTLY- OR AS PROPOSED. IN
USING KINDERGARTEN ATTENDANCE
THE PROXY WOULD RESULT IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVING A
PORTION OF THE FUNDS THIS YEAR
AND SO ESSENTIALLY THAT WOULD
YOU KNOW INCREASE THE NUMBER
VALLEY AS AND THEREFORE- THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDS RECEIVED BY BY
EACH OTHER. IT WOULD BE
IMPACTED AS WELL. THANK YOU
DOES A COMPLETE THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IT DOES THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU. ARMEN OF
OPEN WITH QUESTIONS AND I THINK
I HAVE TO JUST START ASKING
EVERYBODY ABOUT WHAT THEY JUST
SAID. BECAUSE THERE WERE SOME.
ISSUES BETWEEN PEOPLE AND- LET
ME START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ASK. HOW YOU WOULD
RESPOND TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
DIFFERENT WAYS SPENDING
PRESCHOOL AND THE UNRESTRICTED
FUNDS. R. HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
SAID. BLISS MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO- I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT OUR INTENTION WAS TO
RESTRICT THESE FUNDS FOR- THESE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES NOT
ONLY FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR- STUDENTS
DOT AND A SCHOOL DISTRICT
MIGHT- THE SITE IS AT RISK- AND
BASICALLY THIS THE GOAL OF THIS
FUNDING IS ALTERNATELY EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION. SO
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH THAT-
SECONDLY IT LIKE HEATHER
COLONIES HAD MENTIONED- IF THE
FUNDS ARE PUT INTO THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION BASE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PRESCHOOL
SERVICES. AND NOTHING CURRENTLY
A STOPPING A SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM CONTRACTING WITH A SOFA OR
ANY OTHER REGIONAL CONSORTIA TO
PROVIDE PROGRAMMING FOR THEIR
PRE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. AND.
IN THE TOWN I CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS THEN LET ME ASK ONE
OTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT RESPONSE DAILYO.
BUT THE- DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION INDICATED THAT
CHANGING THE FORMULA EXPANDS
IT. TO DOUBLE COUNTED AND MOVE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEN IN A
DE FACTO WAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
SPREADING IT IN A MORE BROADWAY
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
WOULD GO TO INDIVIDUAL L. A. H.
FOR THIS PURPOSE HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT CONCERN. AND
THAT IS ALSO OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF IF THIS WERE TO GO THROUGH
THE BASE- WHAT DOUBLE COUNTED
CANDOR KINDERGARTEN EDA. AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF CHILD FIND
AND SERVING PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN NOT CHARTER SCHOOLS
SO. AND THAT IS A FOUNDED
CONCERNED. IF IT'S A FOUNDED
CONCERNED DOES THAT MEAN YOU'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS IT SOMETIME
HOPEFULLY BEFORE THE MAY REVISE.
AT AS OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL
STANDS THE- THE FUNDING WOULD
ONLY GO TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE SERVING PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. EVEN IF THE USERS ARE
YOURS HE SAID IT WAS UNFOUNDED
CONCERN BUT THEN YOU JUST SORT
OF SAID IT WASN'T TRUE- WHERE
ARE WE HERE IN TERMS OF WHAT
SORRY ABOUT DOUBLE COUNTING AND
BRING IN CHARTER SCHOOLS IN. SO
THAT THE CONCERN IS ABOUT THE
ELLIOTT THE L. A. IS PROPOSAL
TO DOUBLE COUNT
KINDERGARTENERS- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS.
AN ALLOCATION BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF PRESCHOOL STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS SERVING AND
SO ONLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS SO WHICH-
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WAS
ACTUALLY SPEAKING TO THE L. A.
O.'S PROPOSAL WHEN THEY SAID
THAT NOT. YOURS CORRECT OKAY.
THEN BOB LET ME GIVE THE L. A.
O. WITH CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
WHAT THE OTHER TWO ENTITIES
SAID ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATION-
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT. THEIR
CONCERNS ARE EITHER OF CONCERN
OR NOT OF CONCERN- I THINK WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
BALLOTS AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I WOULD JUST SEE IN
TERMS OF POTENTIALLY DILUTING-
SAID THEIR POLICY OBJECTIVES
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
VERSUS THE ALLEY ELSE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS JUST TO AUGMENT THE
BASED INCLUDE PRESCHOOLERS. I
THINK I MEAN UNDERLYING- OPEN
QUESTION IS REALLY HOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS THOSE
FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO BE USED I
THINK IT'S UNCLEAR RIGHT NOW AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THOSE PLANS
ARE ON RESTRICTED WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE RESTRICTED I THINK
BECAUSE A LOT OF THAT AND IS
THROUGH INTENT LANGUAGE IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW DISTRICTS WILL
FOLLOW. HOW CLOSELY THEY WILL
FOLLOW TO THE INTENT TO UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT'S
STILL VERY MUCH FROM OUR
INTERPRETATION IT'S THEIR VERY
MUCH POSSIBLE THAT DISTRICTS
COULD USE THIS FUNDING TO FIND
EXISTING PRESCHOOL SERVICES-
OUR INTERPRETATION IS THAT THAT
IS ALLOWED UNDER HELD A
PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY WRITING
BECAUSE IT IS MAINLY THROUGH
INTENT LANGUAGE. AND SO WE
THINK THAT THOSE CONCERNS CAN
IT KIND OF STILL APPLY IN THAT
SENSE IN TERMS OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ASPECT I THINK THERE ARE
DEFINITELY WAYS FOR US TO NOT
DOUBLE COUNT KINDERGARTEN FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE HOW BIG OF A
CHALLENGE IT WOULD BE FOR SEAT
BUT IN TERMSOF- JUST
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE
RECOGNIZING THAT TERM SCHOOLS
DO NOT SERVE THIS. AGE GROUP
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN- CONSIDER
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE FINAL
DETAILS OF A FOLLOWING A
RECOMMENDATION TO LOOK LIKE AND
THEN I WOULD JUST SAY IT MORE
GENERALLY- I THINK THE REASON
WHY WE WOULD PREFER AN APPROACH
SHOULD EXPAND THE BEAST IS JUST
THAT IT WOULD STREAMLINE HOW
THE STATE PROVIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING. AND THEN IT
WAS ADDITIONAL FUNDS THIS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD LOOK AT MORE
TARGETED LEADS TO PROMOTE THESE
POLICY OBJECTIVES SUCH AS
INCLUSION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION WE THINK PROVIDING
IT IN A YEAR- IN THE PRESCHOOL
GRANTS SUCH AS THE ONE PROPOSED
BY THE GOVERNOR WE THINK IT'S
VERY POSSIBLE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MIGHT ALSO BE
LOST IN IN THE WAY THAT THAT
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED AS WELL.
THERE'S NO REPORTING THAT WHAT
WE WOULD REQUIRE FROM DISTRICTS
MONEY SPEND THIS FINDING AND
BECAUSE OF THAT RATHER VIEWS
NATURE. OF THIS INTENT LANGUAGE
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY UNCLEAR IT'S
NOT. CLEAR WHAT THE- OBJECT. OF
FUNDING ACTUALLY. THANK YOU.
AND I THINK I COULD KEEP GOING
FOREVER WITH EVERYONE BUT LET
ME IN A LAST CALL THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A
CHANCE TO RESPOND TO WHAT BOTH
THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE L. A. O. JUST SAID. THANK
YOU SENATOR I THINK THAT WE
WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THAT OUR
POLICY CONCERNS ARE NOT ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT
ACTUALLY OF THE L. A. O.'S
PROPOSAL AND WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES MORE CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS AS
HEATHER OUTLINED. IN HER
COMMENTS. THANK YOU THEN. I'M
GONNA SEE OTHER. MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS BUT LET ME JUST MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT WHICH IS. IT
SEEMS THAT THERE'S STILL SOME
WORK TO DO IT AT LEAST
UNDERSTANDING. OF WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE. EVEN IF OF PEOPLE
BELIEVE THEY KNOW WHAT THEY
THINK THE IMPACTS ARE BUT SO I
JUST HOPE YOU'LL USE THE TIME.
BETWEEN NOW AND WALKING DOWN
THE MAY REVISED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S CLEAR. THAT I'M
TOTALLY FINE IF YOU DISAGREE ON
THE SUBSTANCE AND WE CAN SORT
OF. FIGUREOUT WHAT WE THINK ON
THAT TOO BUT IT BE NICE IF
THERE WAS SOME AN AGREEMENT ON
WHAT THE INTERPRETATION REALLY
MEANS SO THAT. WE CAN DECIDE
WHAT IT IS THAT. WE WOULD HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THOSE ITEMS
SO LET ME ASK YOU EITHER.
SENATOR MEN RITUAL BOGUS YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS GIVE US CENTRO
TROUBLED. THE MORNING AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING- AND
I DO UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE FORMULAS OF HOW TO
FIND. THE SPECIAL NEEDS AND THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU WOULD HAVE.
AS HAVING THE FUNDS BEING
RESTRICTED OR UNRESTRICTED- AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A SOME
SORT OF LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FUNDS.
IF UNRESTRICTED. ARE SET ASIDE
SPECIFICALLY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION- SO IF WE COULD SEE
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT IN
MAKING SURE THAT IT DOES REALLY
TRULY GO TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL- I DO
HAVE A QUESTION- DEGENERES
FIRST THE TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN AND TWENTY BUDGET ACT
WHICH- PROVIDED. FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY TWO. POINT SEVEN
MILLION TO CREATE THE EARLY
INTERVENTION PRESCHOOL GRANT
PROGRAMS. THIS PROGRAM AWARDS
FUNDS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
THREE TO FIVE YEAR OLDS. WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND PROVIDES
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS-
APPROXIMATELY IN FUNDING PER
CHILD. THE FUNDING IS ALSO
UNRESTRICTED WHICH FEEDS UP
FUNDS FOR OTHER DISTRICT NEEDS.
KEEPING IN MIND MY QUESTION IS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE- IF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. EARLY NUMBER
CHEN GRANTS WERE TO ALIGN WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FORMULA. FOR AWARDS DO YOU KNOW
THE INCREASE IN PER PUPIL
FUNDING THE DOLLARS WOULD
PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE. WITH THE
FUNDING INCREASED BY A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SE PER PUPIL. I'M
SORRY IT MEMBER COULD YOU
REPHRASE THAT I DON'T THINK I
QUITE UNDERSTOOD. SO BASICALLY
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT THE TO
FUNDING FORMULAS RIGHT NOW WOOD
WHICH ONE WOULD CREATE A BETTER
FUNDING THAT NUMBER- MORE. IT
WAS A LUCRATIVE BUT A BETTER
FUNDING NUMBER FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR FOR THE ENTITIES
THAT ARE PRESENTING ARE USING
THESE FUNDS RECEIVING THESE
FUNDS. ARE ARE YOU REFERENCING
THE ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN- THE
GRANT PROGRAM VERSUS THE LA IS-
PROPOSAL. THE ONE THAT YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW SO YOU'RE COMPARING
THE TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THAT PROVIDED FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO CREATE THE
EARLY INTERVENTION PRESCHOOL
GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT IN
COMPARISON TO WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW I'M FOR PROPOSED WHAT
WHICH ONE WOULD ACTUALLY CREATE
A BETTER FUNDING NUMBER FOUR AT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. L. A. C.
THANK YOU SENATE THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE SAME GRANT PROGRAM
AND I WILL PASS THIS OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE. AMBER ALEXANDER.
THANK YOU SENATOR- AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- AS MY COLLEAGUE LIZ
WAS MENTIONING THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE VERY SIMILAR THE
DIFFERENCE THIS YEAR IS THAT
THERE'S A LOOK AT THERE'S A
MORE TARGETED FOCUSED ON-
PRESCHOOLERS- INSTANCE THE
DISABILITIES WERE BEING SERVED
IN INCLUSIVE SETTINGS. BUT THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY BETWEEN
ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN AMOUNT
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS THE
SAME AND BOTH HAVE THAT FOCUSED
ON AND THE PRESCHOOL CAMPS. SO
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING WOULD BE
EXACTLY THE SAME EVEN THOUGH IT
WOULD BE A DIFFERENT FORMAT OR
FORMULA FOR FUNDING. THE
FORMULA ITSELF IS THE SAME.
AMOUNT IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
SAME BECAUSE THE TWENTY
NINETEEN AMOUNT AS YOU AS YOU
SAID IT WAS FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE MILLION. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS- THREE
HUNDRED BILLION SO THERE IS
GOING TO BE EIGHT EIGHT
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT'S RECEIVE
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS- YOU KNOW
LESS LESS MONEY BEING ALLOCATED
IN PROPOSAL THIS YEAR- BUT THE-
FORMULA ITSELF. IS THE SAME
BETWEEN BOTH- BOTH PROGRAMS.
OKAY SENATOR IF I MAY. ARE
GARNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WE ESTIMATE ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED PER PUPIL ON
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE NINE
THOUSAND PER PUPIL IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE
THE GRANT AMOUNT WAS GREATER SO
IT WAS NINE THOUSAND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND FOR US
THAT WE APPROXIMATE ABOUT FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED IF WE USED THE
FORMULA USED THIS YEAR AND THE
NUMBERS YET- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL CURRENTLY. FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED. OKAY. SO MY SECOND
QUESTION WOULD BE. THIS
QUESTION IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ON THE CURRENT
AWARDS FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION EARLY INTERVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. OF THAT INITIAL
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION PROVIDED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND TWENTY
HOW MUCH HAS BEEN AWARDED.
AMBER ALEXANDER AGAIN A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- FACT
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS ABLE TO SPEAK TO
I KNOW- YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT THE ONLY- MENTIONED ABOUT
THAT FUNDING BEING
UNRESTRICTED- I DON'T. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT- IN TERMS
OF SPECIFIC OUTCOMES THAT WERE
REPORTED AND FROM THE DIRECT
USE OF THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH IT WAS ALLOCATED BASED
ON PRESCHOOL COUNTS FOR. EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES THE
FINDING WAS UNRESTRICTED TIMING
COULD BE USED FOR A VARIETY OF
PURPOSES. WHEN YOU SAY USED FOR.
ARE YOU INTENDING TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE OTHER SERVICES THAT
COULD BE USED OTHER THAN
SPECIAL SERVICES. FOR THE
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN YES AS IT WAS
UNRESTRICTED FUNDING OKAY- SO
IT WAS NOT REQUIRED TO BE USED
SPECIFICALLY FOR. EARLY
INTERVENTION PRESCHOOL SERVICES
IT WAS ALLOCATED- FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT IT WAS UNRESTRICTED
SO- LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
THAT HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS
OF HOW BEST TO USE THOSE
DOLLARS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. SO
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S BEST TO
HAVE IT RESTRICTED IF WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S IT GOES
TO TOWARDS THE INTENDED SPECIAL
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL. PROGRAM I
THINK THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
DEPEND ON HERE YOU'RE ASKING I
KNOW- IN THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
WE DID TRY TO STRIKE MARC THAT
BALANCE BETWEEN. GIVING
DISTRICTS SOME FLEXIBILITY BY
BUT ALSO GIVING THEM DIRECTION-
IN TERMS OF. OF EXCLUDING IN
THE LANGUAGE THAT THE FUNDING
SHALL BE USED FOR SERVICES.
THAT SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
READINESS OF- AT PEOPLE'S M. H.
YOU KNOW BIRTH TO FIVE WHO ARE
CERTAIN INCLUSIVE SETTING SO WE
TRIED TO GET. MORE DIRECTION
BUT ALSO STRIKING THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN- NO NOT TOTALLY
RESTRICTING THE FUNDS BUT- IN
ALLOWING SOME FLEXIBILITY. OKAY
YOUR QUESTION. CENTER MEN AND-
SENATOR MEANT. THANK YOU
TRAILER TO FIVE THANK YOU FOR
THE WITNESSES FOR TESTIFYING I
JUST HAD ONE QUESTION. I THINK
IS A CLARIFYING QUESTION- AND
INTO THIS WOULD BE FOR FINANCE
AND EDUCATION- DOES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL EXCLUDE
COUNTY OFFICES EDUCATION FOR-
APPLYING FOR THESE- SPECIAL
EDUCATIONAL INTERVENTION GRANTS.
I DON'T LOSE MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO AND THE- CORRECT-
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATIONAL
NOT RECEIVE THESE FUNDS ONLY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WELL BUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN ABSOLUTELY
CONTRACT WITH THEIR COUNTY
OFFICES OF AT. TO SERVE THEIR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WAS
THERE A REASON FOR THAT I KNOW
IN ORANGE COUNTY- WE HAVE- OUR
OFFICE EDUCATION HAS A PRETTY.
OVER AND SPECIAL NEEDS AND SO I
GUESS WHAT WAS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT. THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT WAS- ONE
OF WHO ULTIMATELY HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SERVING THIS
AGE GROUP WHICH IS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT- MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
COUNTY OFFICES OF ADD TO HELP
SERVE THIS POPULATION- I WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAYBE
THANKS WHETHER I THINK ABOUT
WHETHER IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO
ALLOW COUNTY OFFICES EDUCATION
ALSO APPLY FOR THESE FUNDS. I
JUST AVOID THE MIDDLE MAN AND
SOME OF THAT FRICTIONS THAT
MIGHT RESULT FROM HAVING TO
HAVE THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
APPLY FOR THIS. THANK YOU THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR MAN THANK YOU
TO OUR PANELISTS OF THAT
COMPLETES OUR CONSIDERATION OF
ISSUE ONE AND JUST TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT WE WILL DO
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
ALL SIX ISSUES. WILL MOVE TO
ISSUE TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
MEDICAL BILLING. AND AMAZINGLY
IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME PANEL SO
WE'LL HAVE WAS MINE AMY LEE
ELLIE GARNER IN THAT ORDER SO.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND WE'LL START WITH WAS MORE.
EKET LIST MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE BUDGET INCLUDES
FIVE MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO SELECT
TWO OR MORE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO CONVENE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS
IN DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE
STATE THAT WILL SUPPORT. A
LIAISE AND SUCCESSFUL
PARTICIPATION IN THE ALLEY
EIGHT MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM. AND THIS. UGH THESE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WILL
HELP IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES IN
REGARDS TO THE MEDICAL BILLING
AND PROVIDE PEER TO PEER
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD
CAPACITY IN THIS AREA. IN
ADDITION THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO A SINGLE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY WITH
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN
SUBMITTING CLAIMS TO THE ALLEY
A MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM AND OTHER MEDICAL
BILLING PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE IN BUILDING CAPACITY.
THIS AGENCY WOULD WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO
DISSEMINATE BEST PRACTICES AND
RESOURCES AS WELL SERVE AS A
POINT OF CONTACT FOR OTHER
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
THIS AGENCY WOULD ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEDICAL
BILLING WORK GROUPS MEET AT
WORKGROUP MEETINGS CONVENED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THESE PROPOSALS
ADDRESS SOME OF THE PRELIMINARY
NEEDS AND TEAMS IDENTIFIED IN
THE SB SEVENTY FIVE WORK GROUP
INTERIM REPORT. I'M
PARTICULARLY THE NEED FOR
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TO FILL
KNOWLEDGE GAPS ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS. THESE PROPOSALS WILL
ALSO. PUT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS NECESSARY FOR ONE FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS DO COME OUT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE WILL
MOVE TO EMILY. EMILY WITH L. A.
AGAIN THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
DISTRICTS NEED MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO
SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATE AND
MALEATE MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM HOWEVER GIVEN THAT THE
MEDIC HELD BILLING- THERE'S A
WORK GROUP CURRENTLY EXAMINING
THESE ISSUES THAT THEY'LL HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS OUT TO- ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD BE OUT BY
OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR. WE THINK
THESE PROPOSALS ARE RATHER
PREMATURE I'M FOR THE MORE IN
THAT GOT IN THE WORK GROUP'S
INTERIM REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED THIS PAST OCTOBER
THERE WERE HIGHLIGHTS OF
POTENTIAL NEED FOR A STATE
LEVEL LEADERSHIP WHICH YOU WAKE
ME BETTER ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT SCHOOLS ARE FACING
RATHER THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE WE
ASSESS THE MEDICAL BILLING
PROPOSALS FOR THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROCESS
AFTER IT HAS HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW OF THE FINAL. WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN REMOVE THE L. A.
GARNER FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN TOO LONG.
SAID THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ELEAZAR
ACCESS FEDERAL MEDICAID FUNDS
THE S. S. P. I. HAS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED HOW MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT ELEAZAR ARE
MISSING OUT ON TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT BUT WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THE REIMBURSEMENT IS
ACTUALLY PROVIDING THE KINDS OF
SERVICES ARE CHILDREN SO
DESPERATELY NEED. THIS IS AN
ISSUE HAS BEEN ONLY MAY ONLY
HAVE BEEN MADE MORE APPARENT BY
THE PANDEMIC ACCORDING THE
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ONLY FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE ELEAZAR
PARTICIPATED IN THE MEDIC HOW
BILLING PROGRAM IN FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN A NUMBER
THAT HAS INCREASED BY ONLY ONE
ALLEY A PER YEAR SINCE FISCAL
YEAR TWELVE THIRTEEN. THOSE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
ELEAZAR CLAIMED A HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION A DECREASE OF FIFTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION OR ABOUT
10% FROM THE HIGH CLAIMED IN
FISCAL YEAR FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
THESE NUMBERS SHOWED THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR ACTION IN THIS
SPACE AND IT IS VERY REAL. THE
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
ADAM IS JUST ONE PART OF THE
ABOVE AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
THIS NEEDED SOLUTION I WOULD
KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL WORK IS
NEEDED AS WELL WHICH INCLUDES
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INCENTIVIZE MEDICAL MEDIC HOW
PLANS TO INVEST IN DELIVERING
CRITICAL SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
AND WORK THAT THE ASSETS YEAH I
HAS DONE TO EXPAND THE NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXPERIENCE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
ALLEY A BILLING BEYOND THE
MEDICAL PLANS THEMSELVES THERE
ARE ALSO SOME SOME OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS SUCH
AS CRITERIA AND ELEAZAR ALEXION
PROCESS THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO CLARIFY. WE WOULD ALSO JUST
NOTE THAT GIVEN THE APPOVAL OF
THE AMENDMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAID STATE
PLAN LAST YEAR MEDI CAL BILLING
TO EXPAND MAYBE EXPANDED TO
PEOPLES THAT DO NOT HAVE AN I
EP THERE FOR OPENING UP THE
PROGRAM FOR MORE SERVICES THAN.
JUST THOSE THAT FALL UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW TO BEST
FIT ALL OF THESE PIECES
TOGETHER SO THAT OUR CHILDREN
GET THE SERVICES THEY THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED WHILE ENSURING
OUR SCHOOLS AREN'T BREAKING.
THE BANK IN THE PROCESS I HAVE
WITH ME AGAIN SERRA NOVEL.
DEPUTIES YOU. OF OPPORTUNE FOR
ALL BRANCHES CDT ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS.
CONCLUDES OUR REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M GOING TO
BEGIN WITH A QUESTION FOR THE
L. A. O. ANDTHEN PASS FINANCES
AND- THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO RESPOND. AND THE-
THE L. A. O. SAID THAT. THERE
IS ATASK FORCE COMING IT'S
GONNA REPORT IN OCTOBER. AND
SUGGESTED THAT WE NOT DEAL WITH
THIS BUDGET HERE WITH THIS
ISSUE. AND I WAS GOING TO ASK
IF THERE IS THE L. A. O. AND
THEN ASKED FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
COMMENT. DO YOUTHINK THERE ARE
THINGS ON WHICH THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY COMMON AGREEMENT THAT
WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE URGENCY AND
NOT WAIT. UNTIL OF THE TASK
FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND.
SENATOR I THINK THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION- AND I THINK
I'M I'M NOT ENTIRELY SURE THAT
I HAVE A CLEAR SENSE AS TO WHAT
THE CONSENSUS PROBLEM AREAS ARE
I THINK THERE IS A NEED FOR
MORE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. FOR DISTRICTS IT I
THINK IT REMAINS AN OPEN
QUESTION AS TO WHO AND WHAT AND
SEES WOULD BE BEST SERVED TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WHETHER OR NOT THAT SHOULD BE
STATE LEVEL LEADERSHIP THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE. SERVICES OR IF WE
SHOULD BE USING THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH WHICH IS TO
IDENTIFY ELEAZAR COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION ALREADY DOING MASS.
SO I THINK THAT THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AND
PERSONALLY I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE
THEN LET ME ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF YOU WOULD
RESPOND. TO THAT COMMENT AND
NOT CONCERNED AND AT THE SAME
TIME IF YOU TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
CONCERNED THAT THEY STILL NEED
CLARIFICATION ON SOME THINGS.
RIGHT LIST MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
CLARIFY. ON THOSE REQUIREMENTS
ARE JUST STILL IN CONVERSATIONS
BUT HAPPY TO COLLABORATE- IN
TERMS OF- EARLY ACTIONS AND
THAT COULD BE TAKEN IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE- WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM THE FIELD FOR IT FOR YEARS
NOW. THIS NEED FOR MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE MORE.
WE'RE COULD POSSIBLY BUILDING
AND- THIS NEED TO FILL IN THIS
KNOWLEDGE GAP THAT EXISTS OUT
IN THE FIELD- AND THIS IS TRUE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT AND- WHAT
REFORMS MIGHT. OCCUR WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS. MIGHT COME OUT
IN OCTOBER AND SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR HHS COUNTERPARTS
WITHIN FINANCE ABOUT- AS ABOUT
ACTIONS THAT CAN BE TAKEN OR
WILL BE TAKEN- BUT-WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE REAL-
SOMETIMES THE- RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN- THE STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCALS CAN BE A LITTLE STRANGE
WHICH IS WHY THIS PROPOSAL-
DOES FOCUS. ON LOCAL CAPACITY
BUILDING FROM LOCALS AND PEER
TO PEER LEARNING- WE ALSO WOULD
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
A NEED TO BUILD THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE CAN
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING WHEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO COME OUT IN
OCTOBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN LET ME GO TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
FINANCE JUST SAID THEY WOULD
WORK WITH YOU ON THE
CLARIFICATIONS OF THE CONCERNS
YOU HAVE. AND I WONDERED IF YOU
HAD ANY COMMENT ON WHAT YOU
THINK SHOULD BE DONE THIS YEAR
BEFORE THE- TASK FORCE MARK
REPORT. LATELY AND THANK YOU
SENATOR A COUPLE NOTES FIRST OF
ALL AT AT CDC WE ARE. HELPING
CO LEAD THIS SB SEVENTY FIVE
WORK GROUP AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT ANYTHING. THAT WILL COME
OUT THIS NEXT OCTOBER WILL BE
ANY DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ALREADY WORKING ON WITH OUR
COUNTERPARTS. AT DH CS AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS I WOULD ALSO NOTE.
THAT AS PART OF THE STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR WERE ALLOWED TO
RETROACTIVELY BILL FOR FIVE
YEARS- AND THAT IMPACTS THE
TIMING PEACE. IN OUR ESTIMATION
ELEAZAR CAN RETROACTIVELY BILL
FOR FIVE YEARS BUT THAT CLOCK
IS ALREADY TICKING. AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT DOES NEED TO HAPPEN NOW
AND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE DOES
NEED TO BE BUILT UP CURRENTLY.
SO THAT WE DON'T LOSE OUT ON
THAT RETROACTIVE BILLING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ELEAZAR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH REMIGES SIR
PRITCHETT THE RESPONSE TO THE-QUESTIONS FOR ME TO REVIEW AND-
IT SEEMS CLEAR LIKE THEY'RE-
THEY'RE- LIKELY MIGHT. BE SOME
PLACES TO STILL GO. IN THIS
THIS JUNE. ABSALOM ME ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR MAN. OKAY
WE'RE GOOD SO LET ME THANK THAT
PANEL- WE REALLY APPRECIATE. OF
THAT DISCUSSION AND IT WAS
HELPFUL REMOVE TO ISSUE THREE
WITCHES PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WE HAVE- PAUL
OFTEN SHARE TURNING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AMY LEE
AGAIN OF FROM THE L. A. AND
TELLING CORDNER GARDNER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER- BEGIN
WITH FINANCE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE MORNING CARE ACT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALL
FINISH YOUR TIME WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
SCHOOLS ARE CRITICAL POINT OF
ACCESS FOR PREVENTATIVE AND
EARLY INTERVENTION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. CULINARY DATA
ALSO SUGGESTS THAT DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY INCREASED AND
CHILDREN DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND PROMOTE WELLNESS
IN SCHOOLS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SEVERAL
INITIATIVES AIMED TO INCREASE
RESOURCES AND COORDINATE
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING I WILL GIVE AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
GOING EIGHT. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION I'M GOING TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MATCHING FUNDS FOR CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. IT WAS
ALSO TWENTY MENTAL. THANKS THE
SCOPE OF SERVICES AVAILABLE IN
SCHOOL SETTINGS AND LEVERAGING
RESOURCES TO STRENGTHEN
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ELEAZAR
COUNTY. THIS FUNDING IS MEANT
TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS A CATER TWELVE STUDENTS
IN A MANNER CONSISTENT WITH A
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH TO SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUR SUPPORT
NETWORKS SUPPORT FOR FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EDUCATORS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS THEY'LL
PROVIDE A ONE DOLLAR NINETY
EIGHT MATCH FOR EVERYONE DOLLAR
BINDING AND COUNTIES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. YOUR
SPENDING PLAN THAT IS DEDICATED
TO A PROJECT THAT SUPPORTS
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS. AT LEAST
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING AND WORK WITH THEIR
COUNTY PARTNERS ON A PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND OF CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH PROJECTS WITHIN THE
COUNTY THREE YEARS SPENDING
PLAN TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES IN
SCHOOL SETTINGS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TWO
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS. THE FIRST IS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT ANY OTHER STATE PARTNERSHIP
BRANDS OF THE PORT THE EXISTING
PROGRAM. IS PROGRAMS AND
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND SCHOOLS AND ADDRESSING
SUICIDE AND DROPOUT PREVENTION
SERVICES. OUTREACH TO HIGH RISK
HIGH RISK YOU. UNDERSTAND OTHER
STRATEGIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
THE PROPOSAL IS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THE MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
RECEIVING PREVENTATIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES MY SCHOOL
AFFILIATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. THE TWO LATTER
PROPOSALS WILL BE DISCUSSED IN
DETAIL DURING THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. THANK YOU
GOODBYE REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. REMOVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. ANYWAY
WHAT THE L. A. L. AGAIN SO
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THAT
PROPOSAL AND WILL BE PUBLISHING
OUR ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS IN THE MEANTIME YOU WANTED
TO SHARE OUR INITIAL ASSESSMENT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE TWENTY FIVE MILLION ON
GOING. OUT NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
TO MATCH COUNTY SPENDING ON
THESE CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
PROJECTS. GENERALLY GIVEN THE
CONCERNS OVER ST MENTAL HEALTH
WE THINK PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING TO INCREASE WILL
BE SERVICES IS REASONABLE
HOWEVER WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. FIRST AND FOREMOST
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL LARGELY
OVERLAPS AND DUPLICATES EITHER
A SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH BUDGET
PROPOSALSCURRENTLY PENDING
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
INSTANCE AS FINANCE MENTIONED
IN THIS BUDGET THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO AUGMENT A SEPARATE
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
COUNTY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS.
THESE EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS
AND THE MATCHING FUNDS SHARE
MANY SIMILARITIES BOTH ARE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS
TARGETED TO COUNTY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS TO INCREASE SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THE MOST NOTABLE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THE MATCHING FUNDS ARE
ADMINISTERED BY CD EACH SCHOOLS
RATHER THAN THROUGH A STATE
COMMSSION TO COUNTIES AS IS
THE CASE WITH EXISTING
PARTNERSHIP GRANTS. HOW THESE
PROPOSALS ARE INTENDED TO BE
CORONATED IS STILL UNCLEAR
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE MATCHING
FUNDS PROPOSAL COULD ALLOW
DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE GRANTS
FROM BOTH PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOCUSED ON STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING
WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE MATCHING
FUNDS THESE ACTIVITIES COULD
ALSO BE FUNDED UNDER OTHER
PENDING PROPOSALS AS WELL.
SECONDLY WE ARE ALSO UNCERTAIN
IF THE MATCHING FUNDS WOULD
ULTIMATELY INCREASE COUNTY
SPENDING ON CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH AS INTENDED. THE STATE
DOESN'T COLLECT DATA ON COUNTY
SPENDING ON CHILDREN'S SERVICES
MEANING IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT
TO KNOW WHETHER THE PROPOSED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WOULD MATCH
NEW COUNTY SPENDING OR WOULD
MATCH EXISTING FUNDS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DEDICATED TO THE
SERVICE SAYS. LASTLY I THINK WE
HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE LIKELY IMPACT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. LARGELY DUE TO THE
LACK OF A LOT AVAILABLE TO. ARE
STATING IS THAT MY OF THESE DO.
WILL LEFT UP TO. AND THEY-
DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD TO DECIDE.
AND AS A RESULT IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW THESE APPLICATIONS WOULD BE
PRIORITIZED AND WHAT THE
ULTIMATE IMPACT OF THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENTS AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE WILL BE
RECESSED ARE RELEASING UR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE COMING
DAYS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE MEAN TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW MOVED ONLY GARNER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALEXANDER ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE SS PI HAS
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED HOW THIS
PANDEMIC HAS PRESENTED MANY
CHALLENGES TO STUDENTS
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS. STUDENTS
WHO ARE ALREADY COPING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
THE CHANGES IN THEIR LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT BROUGHT ON BY THE
SWITCH TO DISTANCE LEARNING.
HEALTH WILL BE CRITICAL MOVING
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE SEVERE
TRAUMA OUR STUDENTS HAVE
EXPERIENCED DURING THIS CRISIS.
AND THOSE THOSE TRAUMAS CAN
HAVE A LASTING IMPACT ON THEIR
ABILITY TO LEARN AND SUCCEED.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
COMPETITIVE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
MATCH PROPOSED COUNTY
EXPENDITURES FOR CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. THIS IS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF INVESTMENT THAT IS
NEEDED RIGHT NOW WELL THE
AMOUNT MAY BE SMALL WHEN
COUPLED WITH OTHER EFFORTS SUCH
AS SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S OTHER
PROPOSALS AROUND MEDICARE
BILLING DISCUSSED IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. AND ADDITIONAL
EFFORTS BY THE SS PI. THIS WILL
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT FOR
STUDENTS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THIS CRITICAL NEED. AND AGAIN I
HAVE WITH ME SERENATA. AND
BARBARA MURCHISON THE DIRECTOR
OF THE EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND
EQUITY DIVISION TO ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE FOR CD. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
REMARKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A WOMAN BEGIN WITH A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE. A.
M. THE FIRST ONE IS THAT-
COLAIO SAID THAT- A PIECE OF
THIS DUPLICATES EXISTING-
PROGRAMS HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
TO THAT. WELCOME TO SHAKE HANDS
APARTMENT FINANCE. SO WHILE
THERE IS SOME OVERLAP. E'VE
SEEN THE PROPOSAL'S ATTACKING
THE ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH IN
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES. ARE PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND MATCHED
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS BY FOCUSING
ON PROVIDING SUPPORT NETWORKS
IN SCHOOLS. WHILE THE OTHER TWO
PROPOSAL SEEMS TO PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICES- ANOTHER
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS
MATCH AND ARE OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS THE MATCH WHICH WILL. IN
COUNTY SPENT MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUNDS ALL HEALTH ACT
LANDS ON SCHOOLS SHALL WE KNOW
THAT SOME COUNTIES HAVE A
BALANCE IN AN HSA FUNDS AND WE-
WE WALK UNTIL TYTUS- THAT
TOWARDS CHILDREN. HEALTH
SERVICES. FROM THAT RESPONSE
TEES UP THE SECOND QUESTION I
HAD BECAUSE I WAS ORIGINALLY
GOING TO ASK JUST HOW FAR YOU
THOUGHT THE REACH WAS FOR
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. WHAT DO
YOU EXPECT TO SERVE AND. IT WAS
SAID IN ONE OF THE OTHER- PRESS.
THAT THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT IS
MATCHED. IS IT ALREADY BEING
DONE FOR OTHER SERVICES SO. IT
IN ANSWERING THE QUESTION OF
HOW FAR WOULD TWENTY FIVE
MILLION REACH STATEWIDE. HOW DO
YOU KNOW THAT THE ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT'S THE
MATCH IS ADDITIONAL AS OPPOSED
TO JUST SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
DONE NOW SO IT'S NOT REALLY
EXPANDING THE REACH BY. BY
MATCHING WHAT YOU PROPOSE FOR
THE STATURE. I'M HI ACT
PUBLISHER TENS APARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO SIMILAR TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES A
STUDENT ACT PARTNERSHIP GRANTS
WE HOPE SO- AWARD EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY GRAMS AND WE HOPE TO
PRIORITIZE. AND I'LL BE AS YOU
OUTSIDE FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES YOU CAN ACT
PARTNERSHIP GRANTS BUT IN ROCK
DID NOT RECEIVE AN AWARD- AS
LONG AS THEY WOULD. BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROP NINETY EIGHT MATCH.
AND SO. TO TWENTY. OF OUT OF
HOW MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE I MEAN WHAT ARE WE
REACHING OUR WITH EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY GRAMS. I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE IN FRONT
OF ME BUT I'M HAPPY EACH YEAR
AT AND FIND OUT THE INFORMATION
AND AT AND AT BACK TO YOU WITH
THIS TOPIC. OUR OFFICE GET BACK
GET BACK OKAY BECAUSE IT WOULD
WOULD BE OF INTEREST TO TELL US
HOW FAR THIS REALLY GOES AND
THEN I'M NOT SURE I HEARD. A
CLEAR ANSWER ON WHETHER OR NOT
THE MATCH- WOULD ALLOW THINGS
THAT ARE ALREADY BEING DONE FOR
THE MATCH IS REALLY. A REQUIRES
A DISTRICT TO DO. NEW THINGS
WITH THE MATCHING MONEY. I YES
POPULATIONS HEALTH AS PART OF
FINANCE- SO OUR- HOPE IS THAT.
THE COUNTY IS ALREADY PROVIDING
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES YOU SEEN THAT MHSAA
AND- ACTIVISTS PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING WILL GO TO.
SCHOOLS AND EXPAND OUR
COMPLEMENT. THE EXISTING
PROJECTS. WELL NO IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THAT'S NEW FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT WILL BE AN EXPANSION. DO
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHERE THERE
IT'S BEING MATCHED WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S AN EXPANSION
OR IT SOUNDS TO ME FROM WHAT
YOU JUST SAID. THAT IT'S
EXISTING SERVICES SO REQUIRE NO
MATCH DOESN'T RELIEVE MY
COORDINATE BETTER BUT IT
DOESN'T REALLY REQUIRE.
ADDITIONAL SERVICES FROM THE
MATCH. I'M SORRY CAN YOU.
REPEAT YOUR COMMENT PLEASE I AM
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. IF THE
MATCHING FUNDS ARE JUST THINGS
THAT ARE BEING DONE ALREADY SO
IT'S NOT AN ADDITIONAL SERVICE
BEING PROVIDED BY THE MATCHING
FUNDS OR WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS
PREDICATED. ON LIKE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF NEW
EXPENDITURES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM. THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT HERE AND THEN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN THE MATCH THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING NEW. IT SOUNDED TO
ME LIKE YOU'RE ALLOWING THEM TO
TAKE EXISTING SERVICES. AND USE
THAT AS A MATCH THAT THAT'S NOT
REALLY EXPANDING THE REACH OF
MIGHT BE BETTER COORDINATION
BUT IT'S NOT EXPANDING THE
REACH FROM THIS MONEY. I ASKED-
THANK YOU I AM GOING TO HAVE A
PASS OFF. THAT QUESTIONS MY
COLLEAGUE ON THE LISTING.
YOU'RE LISTENING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- WE
CAN DEFINITELY- CLARIFY THE
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT-
WE'RE REALLY- TARGETING THIS TO
LEVERAGE COUNTY THANK YOU HAVE
A BALANCE- IN THE MHSAA
RESERVES- WE WANT IT REALLY
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO PUT MORE
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE. AND TO
PARTNER WITH AT LEAST RECEIVE
THIS MATCH. OKAY THANK YOU. AND
THEN ONE LAST QUESTION FOR
FINANCE AND NOW. IN THE
DISCUSSION OF LOST WHICH PIECE
YOU WERE. SPEAKING ABOUT I
THINK IT WAS A FOUR MILLION BUT
IT WAS ONE TIME. THAT WAS- IN
THE SUBJECT AREA MORE WHAT
pSUCCESSFUL IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU WOULD THEN DECIDE TO
CONSIDER FOR ON GOING. OR IS IT
REALLY FOR ONE TIME IMPACT. AND
THERE'S NO VIEW THAT THIS
WOULD. YOU KNOW COME BACK IN
FUTURE YEARS. I ASKED HEALTH
MINISTER TEN OF THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THOSE
TWO ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS THAT
ARE ONE TIME FANS ARE ATTY
BEING. OVERSEEN BY OUR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY OUR
COUNTERPARTS AT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT BANK FINANCE SO-
THOSE PROPOSALS ARE AND- BE
DISPENSED GOTTEN A SEPARATE I
JUST COMMITTEE BUT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT MAX- WE DO PROPOSED
ONGOING FRIENDS. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SORRY TO. DOMINATE
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM STE AND OTHER
SENATORS. IN SEEING NONE- WHAT
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT
DISCUSSION. THEN WE WILL MOVE
TO ISSUE FOR WHICH IS SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS AND WILL HAVE
MICHELLE VALDIVIA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EDGAR
CABRAL FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND HOW WE GARNER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER AND WILL
BEGIN WITH MICHELLE FAULTY VIA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
MICHELLE AND THE BALLOT THAT
CRIMINAL FINANCE- SO AS LAID
OUT IN THE AGENDA THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TEN
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
ENHANCED SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEY
RESOURCES- OF THE TEN MILLION A
MINIMUM OF FIVE MILLION WILL BE
TO CONTRACT WITH A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY. MOST LIKELY A
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION- TO
THAT APPROPRIATE SCHOOL CLIMATE
SURVEYS AND TO PROVIDE TRAINING
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND DATA
ANALYSIS AND THIS PIECE WE
ESPECIALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
BECAUSE WE ENVISION- THE BULK
OF THE WORK THAT THE COUNTY
OFFICE WILL BE DOING. IS
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES FOR DISTRICTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE
AND INTERPRET THE DATA THEY ARE
GATHERING FROM THE SURVEYS- THE
REMAINING FUNDING OUR MAXIMUM
OF FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
ALLOCATED AS MANY GRANTS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CITED
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS- WE WANT
DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE TO USE
THESE TOOLS HAPPENED FOR UNDER
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT PROCESS
SEES. RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETIMES
DISTRICTS MAY NEED FURTHER
SUPPORT YOU KNOW FOR THE
FUNDING TO DO THIS WORK- WE
ALSO HOPE THAT FUNDING WILL
ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO
ADMINISTER CLIMATE SURVEY EVERY
YEAR AS OPPOSED TO EVERY OTHER
YEAR AS IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED-
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT TO CREATE A NEW
CLIMATE SURVEY OR TOOL. BUT
RATHER TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE USING RELIABLE
CLIMATE SURVEYS I CAN GIVE THEM
INSIGHT INTO THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WITH
EVERYTHING THAT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES ARE GOING THROUGH- AND
WITH COMMUNITY AND DISTANCE
LEARNING- AND PERHAPS YOU KNOW
MORE IMPORTANTLY- THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN GET. RESOURCES TO
DO THE COMPLICATED WORK OF THE
DISAGGREGATED AND INTERPRETING
THAT DATA THAT THEY GATHER FROM
THE SURVEYS- TO INFORM THE
CONTINUOUS. IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS.%
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE QUEST. AFTER ALL THROUGH.
OF YOU WILL GO TO THE L. A. L.
YES GOOD MORNING EDGAR CABRAL
ECLIPSE THAT AMOUNT OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
WE JUST NOTE THAT IN RETURN
YOUR BILL LANGUAGE WE HAVE SOME
SIMILAR QUESTIONS TO THOSE ARE
RAISING YOUR AGENDA- IN IN
TERMS OF ABOUT EIGHT THE
PROPOSAL WE THINK. REPORT TO
CONSIDER AND CLARIFY HELLO THIS
PROPOSAL COMPLIMENTS
INDIVISIBLE CAPE ANY OF THE
STATE'S EXISTING WORK RELATED
TO THE FACT THAT A HEALTHY KIDS
SURVEY. AND OTHER SUPPORT
SYSTEM FOR REQUIRED. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MUSICIANS. MACFADYEN
COSTS. THANK YOU FOR MUCH WILL
MOVE TO GARNER OF THE STATE. OF
EDUCATION. MORNING ALEXANDER
AND HALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AGAIN. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INTEREST IN ASSESSING COMUNITY
NEEDS IN THE WAKE OF CODE
NINETEEN IN DISTANCE LEARNING
AS THE S. S. P. I. HAS STATED
THE PANDEMIC HAS CREATED
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES FOR
OUR STUDENTS FOR FAMILIES AND
FOR EDUCATORS. BEING AWAY FROM
THE CLASSROOMS BEING AWAY FROM
THEIR CLASSROOMS FRIENDS
TEACHERS AND EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES WHILE ADJUSTING TO
DISTANCE LEARNINGHAS BEEN A
LOT FOR STUDENTS TO DEAL WITH
WE MUST DO ALL THAT WE CAN DO
TO ADDRESS THEIR SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH.
THIS IS WHY NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE NEED SERVICES TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH WE WOULD
NOTE THAT CD E. HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS AND MAY SERVE
AS A BETTER ENTITIES TO
FACILITATE THIS PROPOSAL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PROPOSAL.
AND AGAIN I HAVE WITH ME
BARBARA JUSTIN THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EDUCATOR EQUITY AND
EXCELLENCE DIVISION TO CANCER
ANY PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU- I JUST HAD
ONE QUESTION FOR FINANCE AND
IT'S SORT OF IN THE WEEDS- OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CLIMATE
HEALTH AND LEARNING SURVEY. AND
IT HAS AN ACRONYM. I CAN'T
PRONOUNCE CAL. MMHM CAL HI
FRIENDS. STICK OR SOMETHING
HERE- HE HOW WILL THE SURVEYS
DEVELOPED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
DIFFER FROM RECENT EFFORTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THOSE OTHER
SERVICE. AND THE SHELL OF ID
GET DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YES
SUGGESTED I KNOW THE ACRONYM SO
MANY ACTORS- AND JUST TO
REITERATE OUR THE GOVERNOR THE
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES NOT CREATE A NEW
CLIMATE SURVEY- ARE YOU KNOW
ANY NEW TOOL IT'S REALLY JUST
TO GATHER INFORMATION ON- THAT
IT SURVEYS- AND ALSO TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES. TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ON- YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THE DATA THAT THEY GATHER FROM
THE SURVEYS SO DOES A DUPLICATE
TO SURVEY IT RELIES ON THE
OTHER WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IS
THAT WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE THINK IT RALLY
COMPLEMENTS THE WORK THAT AND
THE DEPARTMENT AND OUR OTHER
PARTNERS IN THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. ARE DOING-
YOU KNOW HOW AT LEAST BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND THEN
LET ME JUST ASK IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BUT I'M JUST
GIVING. YOU A CHANCE TO COMMENT
IF YOU'D LIKE. WE APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. WELL
DONE- OKAY- THAT COMPLETES MY
QUESTIONS OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OF THE OTHER SENATORS. NO
WITH NO QUESTIONS FROM OTHER
SENATORS SO THANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP TO THAT PANEL AND
WILL MOVE TO A SCHOOL NUTRITION
UPDATE AND BOTH PRESENTERS ARE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HELEN GARNER AND KIM
FRIENDS AL- AND WILL TURN IT
OVER IN THAT ORDER FOR STELLY
GARMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALEXANDER ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ADMINISTERS AND PROVIDES A
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO OVER THREE
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS
SPONSORS THAT OPERATE ONE OF
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE OR USTA'S. CHILD
NUTRITION PROGRAMS THE SEVEN
FEDERAL CHILD NUTRITION GIVE ME
CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS ARE
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM THE SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM THE SPECIAL MILK
PROGRAM THE CHILD AND ADULT
FOOD PROGRAM. THE USDA FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM SUMMER
FOOD SERVICE PROGRAM AND THE
SEAMLESS SUMMER OPTION. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE INTENDED TO
SAFEGUARD THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR CHILDREN AND TO
PROVIDE NUTRITIOUS YEAR ROUND
ACCESS TO MEALS. THERE ARE OVER
SIX POINT TWO MILLION CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND 59% ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
SCHOOLS IN THEIR FOOD SERVICE
STAFF HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINES OF PROVIDING MEALS SINCE
THE FIRST DAY O THE NATIONWIDE
PANDEMIC. SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THE USDA HAS ISSUED OVER
SEVENTY NATIONWIDE COVE IN
NINETEEN PROGRAM REGULATION
WAIVERS TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS. I
LIAISE HAVE BEEN SERVING MEALS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY TO ENSURE
THE STUDENTS AND CHILDREN IN
CARE HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTHY
MEALS. THEY DO THIS THROUGH
CURBSIDE PICKUP GRABBING GO
ALTERNATIVE MEALTIME PICK UPS
BUS STOP DELIVERIES AND EVEN
HOME DELIVERY. HISTORICALLY
ABOUT 40% OF OUR SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATING IN THE FEDERAL
MEAL PROGRAMS ENCROACH ON THEIR
DISTRICTS GENERAL FUND TO HELP
SUPPORT THEIR FOOD SERVICE
OPERATIONS. OF THE NINETEEN HAS
CREATED ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON
THE SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
ACCOUNTS DUE TO LAST MEAL
REVENUE WILL. INCREASE STATIC
STAFFING COSTS EQUIPMENT NEEDS
AND RISING FOOD COSTS. OVERALL
SCHOOLS STATEWIDE ARE
EXPERIENCING AN AVERAGE OF A
30% DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
MEALS CLAIMS FOR REIMBURSEMENTS.
CITY ABLE UTILIZE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
REMAINS FROM THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET PURSUANT
TO ASK THE EIGHT TWENTY TO HELP
FILL THE REMAINING GAP FOR THE
MONTHS OF MARCH THROUGH AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY. WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE AN ESTIMATE ON
THE AMOUNT OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS NEEDED TO
FILL THAT GAP BUT WE DO BELIEVE
I GAP WILL REMAIN BETWEEN THE
COSTS THAT PROGRAMS HAVEN'T
HEARD. COMPARED TO THE
REIMBURSEMENTS THEY HAVE OR
WILL RECEIVE FOR THIS TIME
PERIOD. WE'RE HEARING FROM OUR
SCHOOL SERVICE DIRECTORS THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THEIR MEAL PROGRAMS
BEYOND SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND THAT
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO SERVE
THEIR STUDENTS. AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE S. S. P. I
SUBMITTED A LETTER JUST LAST
WEEK TO THE USDA. EMPHASIZING
THE NEED TO EXTEND SCHOOL
NUTRITION WAIVERS AND
FLEXIBILITY THROUGH SEPTEMBER.
ADDITIONALLY THE CITY IS
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
IN ADDRESSING THE FUNDING
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE HEARD. I
HAVE WITH ME CAN FRIENDS OUT OF
THE DIRECTOR NUTRITION SERVICES
DIVISION AT CD AND THE TWO OF
US ARE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND I NOTICED YOU
USED THE- ENCROACHMENT WORDS
SOMEWHERE IN THERE. SO YES SIR
THAT YEAH THAT'S ALWAYS
ALARMING- I WANTED TO STAND
BACK AND JUST ASK A MORE
GENERAL QUESTION BECAUSE THIS
REPORT IS FILLED WITH
STATISTICS ON. SORT OF WHAT HAS
BEEN DONE AND I KNOW SCHOOLS
ARE REALLY STEPPING INTO THE
BREACH THERE TRYING TO FEED
PEOPLE WHILE PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING IN PERSON AT SCHOOL SAID
THAT IT'S REALLY HARD. HE THE
QUESTION I WAS WONDERING IS
THIS SORT OF DOCUMENTS WHAT'S
BEING DONE IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
FOOD. BUT I KNOW THERE WAS A
SIXTY MINUTE STORY A FEW MONTHS
AGO ABOUT A SCHOOL IN FLORIDA
THAT ASSIGN SOMEBODY TO TRACK
DOWN EVERY. STUDENTS AND WHERE
THEY WERE ACTUALLY LIVING AND
THEN WHETHER THEY NEEDED
WRAPAROUND SERVICES RELATED TO
HOUSING OR OR DISTANCE LEARNING
THAT WAS FAILING MORE
NUTRITION. I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD SPEAK TO WHATEVER
EFFORTS INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE DOING TO REACH
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
AVAILING THEMSELVES OF THE FREE
AND REDUCED MEALS WHILE SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED IS THERE SOME EFFORT
GOING O TO. TO TRY TO REACH
PEOPLE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. AND
ARE USING IT. SENATOR I HAVE TO
TWO PIECES AT IN RESPONSE THERE
AND I IT WILL BE DIFFERENT TO
CAN FRIENDS ALR DIRECTOR OF
NUTRITION SERVICES WHO REALLY
IS ON THE FRONT LINES OF MAKING
THINGS HAPPEN FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- AND I APPRECIATE HER
BEING HERE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT. WHILE SCHOOL
MEALS ARE ONE ENTITY IN WHICH
WE NOTICED THAT THE FAMILIES
ARE NOT ENGAGED OR NOT BEING
TAKEN CARE OF FOR THOSE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THERE ARE
OTHER OTHER. WAYS THAT WE'RE
SEEING THAT WHETHER THAT'S
ABSENTEEISM OR FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND SO I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE SS PI HAS CREATED A
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT UNIT WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO WORK ON THOSE
SPECIFIC ISSUES AND SUGGESTED A
BRIEF CALL OUT THERE BUT I WILL
HAND IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
KIM FRENZAL TO ANSWER IF SHE
HAS ANY- ANECDOTAL OR-
STATISTICAL EVIDENCE ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING. TO ADDRESS THIS
FAMILIES WHO MAYBE AREN'T
GETTING THOSE MEALS THAT WE'VE-
SEEN IN THE PAST. EIGHT THANK
YOU L. AND I'M CAN FRIENDS ALL
DIRECTOR OF NUTRITION SERVICES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND AS ALLEY SAID
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
ON THE FRONT LINE SINCE DAY
ONE. AND REALLY TRYING TO
ELEVATE- ACCESS TO THE MEALS
THAT FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
NEED. SO GREAT EXAMPLES THEY
HAVE PARTNERED WITH FOOD BANKS
SO THAT THEY CAN GET FOOD NOT
JUST THAT TO THE CHILDREN
ELIGIBLE FOR SCHOOL MEALS. BUT
FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY. THEY
HAVE. WORKED WITH LOCAL FARMERS
TO HELP SUPPORT THE ECONOMY AND
RESTAURANTS THAT WERE. JUST
GREATLY IMPACTED BY CO THAT
NINETEEN FOR- DONATED FOODS AND
SO THEY REALLY ARE REACHING OUT
TO FAMILIES IN NEED THEY'VE-
BEEN. INCREDIBLY INSTRUMENTAL
WITH- SUPPORT WITH PANDEMIC EBT
AND HELPING CHILDREN GET THOSE
BENEFITS THAT. ARE NECESSARY
AND DOING A LOT OF OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION TO THEM AND I
THINK LA UNIFIED. SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS AN AMAZING EXAMPLE
OF REALLY LEANING AND EARLY ON
TO. FIND COMMUNITY FUNDING
OUTSIDE FUNDING SOURCES THAT
THEY WERE NOT JUST FEEDING THE
CHILDREN BUT THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. AND YOU JUST SEE THE
STATE WIDE AS FAR AS TRYING TO
HELP WITH ALL THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
DURING THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I JUST KNOW FROM
WORKING WITH MY LOCAL FOOD BANK
THAT THEY'RE UP. TWO OR THREE
TIMES NORMAL AND DISTRIBUTION
AND I. I'D I JUST COULDN'T HELP
BUT WONDER IF THERE WERE
CERTAIN. KIDS THAT NORMALLY GET
FREE TO REDUCE MALES THAT THEN
WE'RE SORT OF MOVING OVER TO
THAT BUT THEY DO THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IN THE SAME WAY TOO SO
IN MY VIEW. AND ALLOW ME JUST
BE CLEAR THAT WAS NOT MEANT AS
A CRITICISM BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY'S BEEN WORKING
INCREDIBLY HARD DURING THIS
PANDEMIC JUST WONDERING IF THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT. WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DO BETTER SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER WHEN WE
ASKED THE OTHER SENATORS IF
THEY HAVE A QUESTION NOTHING
FROM SENATOR MEN CENTER- CHAU
BOOK I'M SORRY I HAVE MORE OF A
COMMENT I HAVE AS FAR AS THE
THAT FAMILIES NOT ENGAGING AS
MUCH- COMING FROM A- SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AB ONE OF THE-
ASPECTS THAT WE TRIED TO
MITIGATE WAS. FAMILIES WHO DID
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TRANSPORT THEIR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOLS TO PICK UP THE MEALS.
AND- WE HAD. STE ACCOMMODATED.
AND AN ADDITIONAL STAFF TO COME
IN THAT TO THE DELIVERY OF THE
OF THE MEALS. TO FAMILIES WHO
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO VEHICLES
ARE TRANSPORTATION SO JUST
ABOUT. AND I DIDN'T APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU TO THOSE PANELS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT PROJECT
TO WORK THAT EVERYBODY IS DOING
DURING THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
LAST ITEM ITEM SIX TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
AND WE HAVE UP TO FIVE
PANELISTS HERE. FIRST SERVE
BERGNER AND JENNIFER KACU FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SERV
CORTEZ FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND- WE GARNER
AND SARAH NOBLE MORGAN FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SO WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING OUR- SERVER NOW WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
HERE DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR A COMPETITIVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PROGRAM TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS
AVAILABLE TO SERVE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS. THE
GRANT FUNDING CAN BE USED FOR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES OF CURRENT
T. K. AND KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS
TO SUPPORT THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
INSTRUCTION OR CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO T. K.
PROGRAMS. THE GRANT FUNDING CAN
BE USED FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH CREATING OR EXPANDING T.
K. PROGRAMS AND IT WILL BE
AWARDED OVER MULTIPLE YEARS FOR
THE NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND ELLIE PROPOSES TO
SERVE IN ITS GRANT APPLICATION.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO CONSTRUCT AND RETROFIT
EXISTING FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN. WITH THE
GOAL PROVIDING INCREASED ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE FACILITIE FOR
TEEKAY AS WELL SCHOOL DAY EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING. THAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN COP
PACKAGE IN THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS MY COLLEAGUE CHEN
CAUCUSES ALSO ON THE LINE HERE
WITH ME TODAY COVERING TKA
FACILITIES. AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. THE
MORNING SARAH CORTEZ AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS REGARDING
THE GOVERNOR'S TKA EXPANSION
PACKAGE SO FIRST WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS HAD A
PRIOR INTERESTS IN PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION. HOWEVER IN MOST
RECENT YEARS THE STATE HAS DONE
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION THROUGH THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. SO
WHETHER T. CARE C. PRESCHOOL IS
THE BEST OPTION TO EXPAND
REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
LEGISLATURE GOALS. SECOND WE
NOTE THAT TRANSITIONAL.
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION REQUIRES
ONGOING FUNDING WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS
ONLY INCLUDES ONE TIME BINDING.
WELL THERE ARE SOME ONE TIME
COSTS SUCH AS FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION AND UPDATES THERE
ARE ONGOING COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH I'M SERVING ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS SUCH AS HIRING
ADDITIONAL TEACHERS. THIRD WE
ESTIMATE THE STATE COULD
SUSTAIN ONGOING COSTS OF
EXPANDING G. K. WITH THAT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACIFIC WAY WORSE FOR HIM TO IF
THE STATE ALLOWED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO GENERATE A FULL
YEAR OF ATTENDANCE BASED
FUNDING FOR CHILDREN WITH HER
DAYS AFTER DECEMBER SECOND.
HOWEVER THIS WOULD LIMIT THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO MAKE MAJOR
ONGOING PROGRAMMATIC HATEFUL
AUGMENTATION OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. LASTLY WE WOULD
NOTE THAT T. HE EXPANSION IF
SUCCESSFUL WOULD HAVE A
SIZEABLE IMPACT HONESTY
PRESCHOOL WOMAN. ALTHOUGH THE
PROGRAM CONSERVE YOUNGER
STUDENTS ROUGHLY 63% OF PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS ARE FOUR YEAR OLD.
CLARIFYING THE RULES DEEPLY
SCHOOL WOULD ENSURE THE STATE'S
EXISTING PROGRAMS OPERATE IN
ALIGNMENT TO BEST SERVE
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE SENATOR ALEXANDER ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FULLY SUPPORT THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
FACILITIES AND TEACHER
TRAINING. I HAVE WITH ME
SERENATA MORGAN SHE'S THE
DEPUTY IS DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
BRANCHES SEAT AND STEPHEN
PROFITER THE DIRECTOR OF THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
DIVISION. TO ADDRESS MORE FULLY
THE PROPOSAL AND TO TAKE A
PRAGMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE SARAH. THANK YOU. THANKS
SO MUCH THEIR NUMBER MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ARE GOING TO OUR
COMMENTS ON THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE G. K. I
WANTED TO START BY GIVING THEM
HE BACKGROUND ON CALIFORNIA'S
PREKINDERGARTEN SYSTEM IN TOUCH
A LITTLE BIT MORE UNLESS
THEY'RE A CORTES HIGHLIGHTED.
AS A REMINDER THE STATE HAS TO
PRE K. PROGRAMS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
OBERNOLTE. THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY JUST OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN. AND
OURS CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM SERVED AROUND A HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND CHILDREN. IN C.
K. 59% MORE FROM THE FREE AND
REDUCED PROGRAM YOUNG. WHILE
FRIEND THAT CSP P. OR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AROUND AND 80% WORK
FROM AND THEN LEASED. WITH
INCOMES BELOW THAT THRESHOLD.
DISTRICTS ARE ALLOWED BUT NOT
REQUIRED TO OFFER THE EXTENDED
G. K. WHERE YOU HAVE YOUNGER
CHILDREN AND THE AGE GROUP
BEING THAT'S FUNDED THROUGH THE
ATV RIGHT CLINTON HAS THESE
PROGRAMS. AS WE DROP MORE INTO
THE INCENTIVE PART AT THAT.
OVERALL REALLY PLEASED TO SEE A
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO PRE K.
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
FROM RESEARCH THAT ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAMS. IS ESSENTIAL TO
REDUCING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
IMPROVING HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES ADDRESSING THE
pADDRESSING SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITIES AND RACIAL
DISPARITIES WE'RE ALSO REALLY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT PRIORITY
FOCUS BY THE ADMINISTRATION. ON
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS TO EXPAND
ACCESS FOR OUR DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. ALL DAY PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT PROGRAMS ARE
INCLUSIVE OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. AND TO ADDRESS
AREAS WHERE THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT DISPROPORTIONATELY
A PARTICULAR RACES OR
ETHNICITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY DISTRICTS
AFFECTS BREAST AND DESIRE IN
THE PAST YOUR EXPANDED THEIR ET
QUE PROGRAMS AND SERVE YOUNGER
CHILDREN. ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
COULD REALLY HELP WITH THAT AS
WELL AS LANDING CSP P. AND G.
K. PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
HOWEVER AS THIS PURPOSE ONLY
FORWARD WE WANT TO ELEVATE THE
IMPORTANCE ALIGNING WITH THE
MASTER PLANNED FOR EARLY
LEARNING CARE IS
RECOMMENDATIONS. AROUND HAVING
A STRONG MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
WHICH INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY THAT MASTER PLAN
HIGHLIGHT ALIGNING AND
STRENGTHENING CURRENT
PROGRAMMING. AND QUALITY
STANDARDS FOR ENHANCED RISK
PROGRAMS. THAT SERVE THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS. ALL INCLUDES
EXPANDING CAL STATE CHRISTOPER.
TO INCLUDE YEAR OLDS WITH.
INCLUSIVE CLASSROOM SETTINGS
THIS WOULD FURTHER SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
AROUND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION AROUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION. THERE'S ALSO A NEED
TO CONTINUE SUPPLYING PRESCHOOL
DURING NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM OF
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC SCHOOL
BASED PROVIDERS TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS SOME
OF THE FULL DAY. ACTUALLY WE
WOULD SAY WELL THEY CLASS THAT
I'LL A LOT OF OUR WORKING
FAMILIES NEED INSURANCE SURE
EQUITABLE. ACCESS BY FAMILIES
AND MEET. IN ADRESSING THAT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TKD AND JAY TEACHERS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND LEARNING FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS. IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT THOSE TEACHING
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS ARE
PREPARING TO UNDERSTAND
DEVELOPMENTAL STAGES AND
PROGRESSION OF LEARNING AND
SKILLS CHILDREN WERE FOUR YEAR
OLDS BUT IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FROM SOMEONE WHO IS EIGHT OR
TEN YEARS OLD. SHE ENSURING
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS. CAN REALLY
POLITICAL INCLUSION. PORTANTINO
LANGUAGE LEARNERS BY ADDRESSING
ONE LANGUAGE STRENGTHENING AS
WELL AS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION. AND TO SUPPORT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING THEIR
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES AND
MITIGATING. BIAS THAT STARTS IN
THE EARLIEST YEARS WE ALSO KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO IMPROVE
THE COMPETENCIES OF TEACHERS.
THEY HAVE MORE OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION COMPONENT
AS PART OF. WE APPRECIATE ALL
THOSE WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
MASTER PLAN COMPONENTS WHICH
REALLY WOULD HELP ALIGN THE
WORKING WORLD ACROSS THE SYSTEM
INTO KINDERGARTEN FIRST AND
SECOND AND THIRD GRADE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
LEGISLATION SURE. ON A DRESSING
THOSE COMPONENTS THAT INCLUDE
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. I
MIGHT HAVE SKIPPED OVER
QUICKLY. JENNIFER KACU AND-
FINANCE DEPARTMENT WAS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT FACILITIES AND I
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU WANTED TO.
SPEAK TO THAT IN ANY WAY TO DO
IT NOW. SHERA ALREADY MADE
THEIR APARTMENT MARKS BUT- IT'S
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR.
INVESTMENT AND- HE CARED FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES-
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS REGARDING FACILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WAS
GONNA ASK A COUPLE OF ROAD
GENERAL QUESTIONS AND PROBABLY.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
FIRST I WAS GONNA ASK HOW MANY
CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED IN EARLY
T. K. NOW. AND HOW MANY MORE
CHILDREN IN BOTH TWO K. AND- WE
T. K. DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
HOPE TO SUPPORT WITH THESE
PROGRAMS- OF THROUGH THESE
BUDGET PROPOSALS. HELLO SIR
BERNARD WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT HOW MANY
CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED IN TWO U.
K. I THINK OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. I
DID A GREAT JOB LISTING SOME OF
THOSE NUMBERS SO WE DEFINITELY
AGREE WITH THEM WE THINK THAT
THERE'S AROUND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND A FOUR YEAR OLDS BEING
SERVED AND T. K. CURRENTLY.
UNDER YOUR SECOND QUESTION
ABOUT HOW MANY MORE CHILDREN WE
ANTICIPATE BEING SERVED WITH
THESE GRANTS- PROPOSALS. WE
DON'T HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER ON
THAT RIGHT NOW BUT WE HAVE
EMBEDDED SOME MEASURES WITHIN
THE LANGUAGE TO. GATHER DATA
ABOUT HOW MANY ADDITIONAL FOUR
YEAR OLDS AREBEING PROPOSED TO
BE SERVED BY ELLIE AS WILL
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS. AND
IT'S- PART OF THE PROPOSAL IS.
INCLUDES AN INTENT TO SERVE.
THESE EXPANDED TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THAT DATA THAT WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE RIGHT NOW. WE
HOPE THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
ELLIE AS- I WILL PUT INTO THEIR
GRANT APPLICATION IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
HERE- SO THAT BY THE TIME THAT
THE GRANT. FUNDING FOR THE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROPOSAL ROLLED
OUT IN THE- FOLLOWING YEARS- WE
WILLKNOW WE WILL HAVE A MUCH
CLEARER IDEA OF THE NUMBER. OF
THAT THAT THESE THAT THIS GRANT
WILL US SUPPORT WELL I THINK I
WAS ASKING YOU KNOW. IN A WAY.
EVEN THOUGH. FORMER VEGETATION
SPOKE TO IT. TO GET AN IDEA OF
WHAT'S IN THE CURRENT YEAR WHAT
MIGHT BE IN THE NEXT YEAR AND
WHERE YOU SEE THIS GOING OVER
TIME WHETHER WHAT'S THE TOTAL
POPULATION. OF PEOPLE ANTI K.
AND ARE YOU REALLY SHOOTING TO
GET IT THIS YEAR BY YEAR BY
INCREASING IT EVERY YEAR THE
STAFF TO STRATEGY AND IF SO.
HOW MANY YEARS DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD TAKE TO GET WHERE YOU
WANTED TO EVENTUALLY GO. THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDES AT WITHIN THE
APPLICATION THAT ELLIE IS WILL
COMPLETE A PROPOSAL FOR HOW
THEY PLAN TO EXPAND WITHIN
THREE YEARS I THINK. TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE HAVE AN INTENT
TO SERVE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WE CAN'T SAY RIGHT NOW
WE CERTAINLY HOPE TO EXPAND
THIS PROGRAM A LOT OF THE
INTENT FOR THESE PROPOSALS IS
TO START SOME OF THESE CAPACITY
BUILDING MEASURES THAT WE NEED
TO EXPAND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN SO THIS IS OUR
FIRST. TAKE OUT THIS WOULD BE
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS AND BE.
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT FUNDS IN THE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM- SO IN
TERMS OF OUR LONG TERM PLAN AND
WE KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS VERY INTERESTED IN EXPANDING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FOUR YEAR OLDS WE DON'T HAVE A
NUMBER ON THAT RIGHT NOW PER SE
BUT WE CERTAINLY ARE VERY
CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT THE TAKE UP
WILL BE LIKE AND TO WORK WITH
OUR- PROGRAMMATIC PARTNERS IN
OUR LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS. TO
ADDRESS THE IMPLICATIONS AND
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE PROGRAMS
MOVING FORWARD. I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THE TERMS TO GETTING
THE DATA AS YOU GO ALONG. BUT
IT WOULD REALLY BE NICE TO KNOW
WHAT YOUR LONG TERM GOALS ARE
IN IT AS WITH ANYTHING IF
THEY'RE MILLION KIDS AND WE'RE
DOING A HUNDRED THOUSAND NOW
AND I KNOW THAT NUMBERS HIGH. I
AM JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
BY YEAR HOW YOU GET THERE AND
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE
COLLECTING. THE INFORMATION
RETROSPECTIVELY IT AND THEN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU'RE
DOING IT AND I JUST THINK IF
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THIS
OVER TIME IT BE GOOD TO KNOW
WHAT THE TOTAL UNIVERSITY IS
IN. AND HOW MUCH WE'RE MOVING
TOWARD IT EVERY YEAR AND WHAT
IT MEANS FOR FUTURE COMMITMENT
SO JUST THAT SOMETHING I WOULD
BE. INTERESTED IN SEEING AS YOU
TALK ABOUT THIS OVER TIME YOU
JUST ANSWERED THE QUESTION BUT
IT IS I THINK IT STILL BEGS THE
ISSUE OF WHAT THESE NUMBERS ARE
OVER TIME AND WHERE. WE'RE
GOING BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT COMMITMENT OF
MONEY IF IT'S GOING TO BE THAT
OVER. TIME OF WHAT IT MEANS AND
WHAT IT'S GOING TOMAIN GO
THERE. THE OTHER. I IS. AND IT
ROUGHER. IN AS WELL. BUT HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION ENVISIONS
STATE PRESCHOOL AND EARLY T.
CURRY. ALIGNING AND THEN
ACTUALLY I KNOW WAS ASKED.
COOPER ALREADY WHY EXPAND. T.
K. AS OPPOSED TO PRESCHOOL-
JUST SO. TALK ABOUT THE
ALIGNING AND WHY THERE'S A
PREFERENCE FOR ONE OVER THE
OTHER WOULD WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HEAR- SO I'LL SAY A FEW THINGS
TO THAT AND SO- TO START I
WOULD NOTE THAT WE ARE NOT
PROPOSING ANY CHANGES TO THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT AS WELL THAT WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO THE MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT AGAIN OUR
OUR CD PARTNERS REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED- DO SERVE QUITE A
FEW FOUR YEAR OLD ARE STILL A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
PROVIDING. PRESCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS- SO THAT WOULD BE MY FIRST
POINT AND THEN TO GET TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHY TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN OVER STATE
PRESCHOOL- AGAIN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS VERY
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING. IN
EXPANDING ACCESS FOR
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES THAT WE
COULD TAKE. THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL REALLY
ALIGNS WITH DATA THAT HAS COME
OUT FROM THE MASTER PLAN WITH
THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
POLICY. OF FEATURES OF THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS CHILDREN TO
BE IN NEXT INCOME CLASSROOMS-
THAT THAT IS REALLY ATTRACTIVE
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
SO. THERE ARE FEW FEATURES OF
TKA THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO LOK INTO AND EXPAND-
AND THAT'S NOT AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
PROVIDES FOR THE FIELD- SINCE.
AND LET ME JUST GIVE A CHANCE
FOR EITHER THE L. A. OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COMMENT ON WHAT WAS JUST SAID
KELLY- DO YOU HAVE ANY THING TO
HAND- AND ALSO I HAD TO GET A
MAY STATEMENT ABOUT- WHAT CAN
REPROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE
MONSTER EXPAND ALTERNATELY
DEPENDS ON ITS OWN SPECIFIC
GOALS. I'M SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
THE LEGISLATURE WANTED TO OFFER
A ONE YEAR PUBLIC SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC PRESCHOOL TO ALL
STUDENTS. ON THE G. K. COULD BE
A BETTER PATH TO EXPANSION
BECAUSE THE STATE COULD USE
SCHOOL DISTRICT CATCHMENT AREAS
AS A WAY TO ENSURE. THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS
TO PRESCHOOL- IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO OFFER
PRESCHOOL TO ALL THREE FOUR
YEAR OLD FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND STATE PRESCHOOL
COULD BE A BETTER PATH TO
EXPANSION. STATE I'M SO THOSE
AREJUST SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS- THAT WE RATES
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS
THINKING ABOUT KIND OF WHAT
WHAT THE PAST EXPANSION AS-
THANK YOU AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ANYTHING TO ADD. YES
THIS IS THEIR NUMBER MARK AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE JUST WANNA ADAM
BALDOCK WITH BOTH OF THIS THERE
IS IT'S ALWAYS THE STAIRS DOWN
EARLY AND I HAVE ALREADY STATED
THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH THAT
STANDS BEHIND MIXED INCOME IN
SETTING. AND SO REGARDLESS
SEVENTY TWO YEARS THE S. B. P.
WE THINK THAT THE STATE NEEDS
TO ADDRESS AND THAT NEED TO
HAVE MIXED INCOME AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT ALL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES COULD BE INCLUDED
SO THAT THEY'RE IN NOT
INCLUSIVE ATTY SO IN ADDITION
TO LOOKING UP OF WORLD WE WANT
TO STRESS THAT THAT MASTER DATA
DROPS THE THREE YEAR OLDS. IN
NOT EXPANSION OF CST KEY TO
INCLUDE ALL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE WOULD
HIGHLIGHT ONCE AGAIN GOING BACK
TO ENSURING THAT CHILDREN WHO
HAD I AT THIS EASIER
INDIVIDUALIZED FAMILY SERVICE
PLANS WHICH GO UP TO AGE THREE
COULD ALSO PARTICIPATE A LOT OF
THE CHILDREN AS THEY
TRANSITION. I GAVE. THAN AREN'T
ELIGIBLE FOR IDA KIRBY WHICH IS
WHAT STARTS IN THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AT AGE THREE AND SO IF
WE WANTED TO ADDRESS MORE MORAL
GROUND DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS OR
PREVENT LATER NEED FOR
PARTICIPATION IN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES THAT. REALLY
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THOSE INCLUSIVE SETTINGS WOULD
BE. IDEAL ALSO THAT WE WOULD BE
AND IN NOT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW S. IF IT OF THE SAN. THE
ROOM I'M A CO CENTERMAN. HI
THANK YOU FOR THIS PURPOSE I
WAS CURIOUS ABOUT HOW IT
COMPARES AND PER INNER WITH AB
TWO TWO. THE BILL- FOR
PRESCHOOL ANTI K. INTRODUCED BY
VARIOUS ASSEMBLY AND SIGNED ON-
BY NUMBER SENATORS INCLUDING
MYSELF HAVE YOU COMMUNICATED
AND INTERACTED WITH ANY THE
PRINCIPAL AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
AND MAYBE YOU COULD GIVE AN
ANALYSIS FOR THE PART OF
FINANCE ON HOW THE PROVISIONS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD COMPARE TO THE PROVISIONS
AB TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
CENTERMAN SO AT THIS TIME- WE
HAVEN'T DIVED SUPER DEEPLY AND
SAID THAT BILL- WE KNOW THAT
IT'S IN THE WORKS AND- I ASSUME
SIMILARLY TO PAST YEARS WHEN A
LOT OF OUR PRIORITIES ALIGN I'M
SURE THAT WE WILL HAVE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. ARE MOVING
FORWARD ABOUT- OUR VARIOUS
INTERESTING PROPOSALS AND
PRIORITIES HERE SO AT THIS TIME
NO WE HAVEN'T HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS QUITE YET BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
YOU AND YOUR PARTNERS AND THE
LEGISLATURE MOVING FORWARD AND-
ON. SHE CAN PRESCHOOL EXPANSION
IDEAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT'S ALL I HAVE
THANK YOU SANDRA TROUBLED. FOR
YOUR GOOD. OKAY THE LET ME
THANK THE- ARE THAT COMPLETES
THE SIX ISSUES THAT- WE WERE
CONSIDERING AND WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO ANYBODY THAT WANTS
TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ANY OF THE SIX ISSUES
AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN DUE TO THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS- I AM GOING
TO PASS THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDE COMMENT THAT
KEEPS TE REMARKS WITHIN ONE
MINUTE. AND AND JUST ALSO
REMIND THAT I WALL ENFORCE
DECORUM IF THERE ANY ISSUES- SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO FIRST TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. DOES
ANYBODY WISH TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE ARE THERE
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE THAT WISHES TO ADDRESS
TO COMMITTEE. SEEING ONE THEN
WE WILL MOVE TO. THE PUBLIC
CONFERENCE LINE A MODERATOR-
WELL FROM BAND- PLEASE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WILL BE
READY TO BEGIN WHEN THEY QUEUE
UP IN A READY. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU MAY
WITHDRAW YOUR QUESTION AT ANY
TIME BY REPEATING THE ONE AND
ZERO COMMAND. IF YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
WRITE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN LINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK I THANK.
OUR MODERATOR WE CANNOT HERE WE
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE PERSON
NOT SPEAKING WELL OR TECHNICAL
CONNECTION. YES I'M NOT HEARING
ANY AUDIO FROM THAT LINE AGAIN
I WILL RELEASE THAT AND ASKED
THEM TO RE PROMPT I WILL MOVE
THE LINE TO THE LINE OF MY
NUMBER TEN LINED TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS. I WANT TO
FOCUS OUR COMMENT SPECIFICALLY
ON ISSUE ONE SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND ISSUE FIVE. ON THE
TRACTION. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THE ONE
POINT FIVE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FACT THAT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS
SPECIAL EDUCATION. AND SCHOOL
NUTRITION REQUIRED THE PAYING
TREATMENT AS THE LPS BACK. AND
WE ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE SAME
COMPOUND AND COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AT THREE POINT EIGHT
FOUR PERCENT. INSTEAD OF JUST
THE ONE POINT 5% PROVIDED FOR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR MODERATOR NEXT BECAUSE-
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN LINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARON NUMBERS AS METATRON WITH
CHILDREN NOW I HAD I'VE BEEN
MENTIONED DURING THE HEARING
THERE'S A DIFFICULT CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE PROPOSAL'S
EXPANSION VISUAL KINDERGARTEN
AND EARLY LEARNING PROVIDED
THROUGH CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL- WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
POLICYMAKERS PROMOTE EXPANSION
OF EARLY LEARNING FOUR YEAR OLD
STREET G. K. THAT IS THE
CENTRAL WI FI MECHANICALLY
STABILIZED. CHILD CARE WITH
THEM I PERSONALLY THINK ABOUT
ALREADY FRAGILE AND IT'S BEEN
I'M BEGINNING TO GET RESTRAINT
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
STABILIZATION WOULD INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE INVESTING IN RATE
REFORM AND EXPANDING ACCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND PRESCHOOLERS. I'M
AT THE SAME TIME WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN THAT
WE ADDRESS SOME OF THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE-
ISSUES ESPECIALLY FOR EVEN
YOUNGER AND FOUR YEAR OLD SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE VERY LARGE- A
TEACHER THAT TO CHILD RATIO.
I'M TRYING TO PROVIDE MORE
ADULTS IN THE CLASSROOM AND
THAT WE ACTUALLY PAY FOR THE
EXPANSION- AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH COMMITTEE
INCENTIVE GRANT BUT- AS WAS
NOTED BY THE L. A. L. THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ONGOING
COSTS. AND I THINK IF WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THAT- I. WE
REALLY GOT A TELL ME SURE. THAT
FUND I TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
NOT TAKE A FUNDING FOR OTHER K.
THREE TWELVE STUDENTS AND THEN
FIND. I WOULD JUST I KNOW THAT
WE'RE REALLY APPRECIATIVE ABOUT
THEM. OF THE SCHOOL COUNTY
HEALTH PART. THEM LOOK FORWARD
WORKING WITH THE SENATE ON THAT
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NECK
SPEAKER. WHAT ARE NAY PUBLIC IT
WILL COME MY NUMBER TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND- I
MISSED SHALL APATHETIC PUBLIC.
BY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS. CAL ISSUED BY TO
COMMENT FAVOR THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLAH. IMPROPER
EIGHT RENOVATED PARK WITH
COUNTY RIVAL PARTNERS. RIGHT
MAKE SERVICES BY THE WEBER IT
MILLION WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
EXPECTED TO MATCH- WITH ON
DEMAND HEALTH- ACT WHEN.
THEY'RE DEDICATED TO MY HEALTH
NEEDS FOR ST. ACCORDING TO RE
STUDY. JIM MEMBERS 87% COUNTY
BE HEALTH AGENT ALL PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. I'M SCHOOLS
AND 50% RIGHT SINCE USE
TREATMENTS ON SCHOOL AS WELL.
BRITISH I THINK THE NINE PERSON
ACCOUNT BE ABLE THE TO. USE AS
MUCH AS THEY FARM PREP SCHOOL
BASED- WITH SOME SCHOOLS
COMBATING STATE FARM'S RESOURCE
TO CHILDREN AND YOU BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT THE- TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATE.
WILL NOT EXPAND ACT YOUR BILL.
SIXTEEN THESE CRITICAL LAW TERM
PART IN THE LONG. WE THANK
COMMITTEE THE TIME THANK YOU
VERY. OF MR. NEXT SPEAKER. OUR
NEXT COMMENT WILL COME TO
NUMBER ONE LINE TO ONE YEAR
LINE IS A- HELLO STILL YOU WITH
TODAY. WHICH IS IN OUR LEARNING.
SERVING THAT ONE CHILDREN IN
THE BEAR- INCLUDE SEVERAL CHILD
CARE CENTERS ON A FAMILY CHILD
NETWORK INSURANCE DISTRICT IT'S
FE- I LIKE TO COMMENT ON A SIX
HUNDRED IN THE- WE- THE GUY.
CAN TO TOWARD UNIVERSAL PRE K.
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLD IN THE
BUDGET. LINE WE WOULD URGE YOU
TO LEGISLATURE IN THE TO GO.
THAN THE PER. AND ACTUALLY FOR
FIND EXPANDED KINDERGARTEN ALL
DISTRICTS YOU CHOOSE TO EXPAND
HE K<c.cyan> SERVE YOUNGER FOR YEAR</c>
OLD. AND A CONDITION NOT
FUNDING ON IMPLEMENTING KEY
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT LIKE LOWER
STUDENT TO TEACHER RATIOS AND A
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
CURRICULUM. WE SEE THIS AS A
STEP- THIS STEP TOWARD
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
FOUR YEAR OLDS AT THE KEY PIECE
IN A LARGER VISION TO BUILD A
STRONG HERE TO FIVE EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM THAT MAKES
DELIVERY- AND THEN ENSURE THAT
EVERY CHILD- REGARDLESS OF RACE
INCOME OR BACKGROUND IS GIVEN
THE STRONGEST CHANCE TO SUCCEED
IN SCHOOL AND IN LIFE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. OUR NAY
PUBLIC WILL COME NUMBER SEVEN
TWO LINE SEVEN YEAR LAW IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN NUMBERS
TO DECIDE BUT I BUT WHAT GROUP
ARE PRETENDING THEY THANK. AS
WE KNOW OF BACK TO HELP FOOD
EXACT BY COULD STATUS IN THE
PREVALENT IN LOW IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOUR PROVIDING FINANCIAL
RESOURCES OR THE TRADITIONAL
PROGRAM ENSURE SCHOOL UP WITH
GENETICALLY A VITAL ROLE IN
THEIR- CHATTING TRICK. UNDER
UNDER WE TOLD. UNFORTUNATELY
THE STATE AND FEDERAL ALLOCATED
FOR FUN PERSONAL NUTRITION
EXPIRED AT THE START OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR BUT THE DOES NOT
HAVE A MERGING THE OPERATIONS
DURING COVER NINETEEN DID NOT
CURRENTLY THERE'S NOBODY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FOR FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
SCHOOL YEAR TO PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR THESE PROGRAMS HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY THERE'S A 30% DROP IN
PARTICIPATION WHICH TRANSLATES
TO A 30% DROP IN REVENUE PER
SCHOOL NUTRITION DEPARTMENT AT
A TIME WHEN THERE'S- THEIR
COSTS HAVE ONLY INCREASED. FOR
THE THREE SOMETHING REJECTED
RESPECT REQUEST ADDITION
FUNDING IN THE TWO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. BUDGET TWO MORE
FOR. BY RESOURCE TO ALL PUBLIC
NUTRITION THE- BASED. BUT BY
DEFICIT IMPEDING STUDENT DURING
pYOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. MISTER MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. ARNETT EXPLICA
MENTAL COMPLY NUMBER FOURTEEN
LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS IS TOM LARGE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NEARLY
A QUARTER MILLION CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES IN K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
EDUCATION THAT IMPACT PROGRAM
HOWEVER WE WANT THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH
ACCESS TO EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES WITH UNIVERSAL I
TRIED TO SHOW CAN GUARDIAN. AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
MENTION RESEARCH SHOWS THAT HE
K. REDUCES THE NEED FOR LATER
HIGH COST INVENTION AND IT
HELPS. WITH CHAU SO CHAU
EMOTIONAL READING AT THE
TRANSITION COOKING GARDENING SO
WE THINK UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR OUR YOUNG LEARNERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT WE OFF OF THE
COURT EIGHT THREE POINT 84%
COLA FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION. IN
CHILD NUTRITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
MODERATOR NEXT TO CALL.
REPUBLICAN WILL COME NUMBER
TWENTY LINE TWENTY EARLY IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MIRED IN MEMBERS OF THE AND I
THE CENTER A LETTER. SUPPORT
AND GROW THAT NETWORK OF NEARLY
A HUNDRED SCHOOL TO AND THERE
WILL WORK TO PROVIDE ALL
STUDENTS WITH SPECIALLY
PREPARED CALIFORNIA GROUNDED AN
EDUCATION AT THE STATE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING SURVEYS
AND INTERVIEWS CORPORATE
DIRECTOR THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. I WANTED TO SHARE
THREE OF THEIR CLOTHES
ILLUSTRATE THE IMPERATIVE FOR
ADDITIONAL. FUNDING THE FIRST
BIG SERVICE DIRECTOR THAD IT IS
AN OLD SEVENTY FIVE BAND MADE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE FOR MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE THE FALL IN
THE MAIL SALES HAVE MEANT SO
MUCH THAT THREATENED NOW. THE
FACT. BUDGET COLLAPSES THE
LOWER DEPARTMENT OUR COMMUNITY
IS VERY LOW INCOME AND RELIES
ON SCHOOL MEALS ARE DEPARTMENT
OF CUT THE QUALITY OF SCHOOL
MEALS WILL SUFFER AND. SO WILL
THE CHILDREN ORLANDO. AND VERY
SAD I DID FUNDING MAKE UP WITH
NO WAY. NEXT YEAR THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION EMPLOYEE. PAID
THROUGH THIS. CRISIS AND WORKS
TO THE PUMP. PLEASE TAKE OF
THEM. BUT RESPECTFULLY THAT IS
FUNDS IN THE TWO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY. CALIBER BUDGET. BOB
SCHOOL NUTRITION. BUT BASS
FISHING ON BUDGET DEFICITS
REPEATING IT IN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A MISSED MONTEREY
NEXT CALLER. OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL COME FROM LINE
NUMBER TWENTY LINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN EMERITUS MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LIZ FENTON AND I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CAT TAYLOR
AND THE CENTER FOR ECO LITERACY
ON ISSUE FIVE SCHOOL NUTRITION.
DEMOCRAT LEE FUNDING PROVIDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ALONGSIDE
THE U. S. STATE USDA WAIVERS
HELPED ENSURE THAT SCHOOL NEEDS
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA. HAVE
ACCESS TO FREE NUTRITIOUS MEALS
WHILE SCHOOLS CONTINUE TO BE
CLOSED. UNFORTUNATELY THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR SCHOOL
MEALS EXPIRED AT THE START OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR AND NO NEW
FUNDING FOR PANDEMIC RELEASE.
FOR THESE PROGRAMS WHILE THE
STATE OPEN WAS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET THIS
FINDING IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
NOW GIVEN THE DIRE FORECAST.
PROJECTED BY GROUPS LIKE THE
SCHOOL NUTITION SSOCIATION
AND THE CENTER FOR ECO
LITERACY. PREDICTING THAT 84%
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
ANTICIPATING THAT LOST IN. TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY. WE ESTIMATE
THAT CAL SCHOOL PROGRAMS COULD
BE FACING AS MUCH AS A FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR DEBT BY THE END OF THIS
SCHOOL YEAR. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. TO DECENT SCHOOL
NUTRITION DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE
STAYED OPEN THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC FEEDING HUNGRY
CHILDREN AS YOU KNOW LACK OF
ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD IS
EXACERBATED BY SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS. AND MOST PREVALENT IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. SIX PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN
LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH OF THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CPU THE CHILD CARE UNION
REPRESENTED BY SEIU AND
ACTUALLY W. I WANTED TO SPEAK
TO ISSUES EXPLODED TO TJ WELL
WE APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL THAT
ALL OF THE HARD WORK. ON BEHALF
OF TJ WE SELECT THE CURRENT
PRACTICE AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND INCOMES AND
TODDLERS ZERO THREE AND HAVING
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE SO WE
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
THE AGE RANGE AND FUNDING
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL- AS IT IS
AN IMMEDIATE NEED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER. MODERATOR NEXT COUPLE.
BOB COMMENT WILL ALIVE EIGHT.
LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE MISSION MCKAY AND WITHOUT
BEING OF THE IS FOR AT FUNDING
FIRST EDUCATION FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THE FUNDING FOCUSED ON
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND SENATOR MAN FOR YOUR
PERSONAL COMMENTS ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION WE SUPPORT
THE DEDICATION OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
BUT BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE CURRENT
FUNDING FORMULA AS RECOMMENDED
BY THE L. A. L. WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WOULD CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT IDENTIFY A
PRESCHOOL WITH DISABILITIES.
AND LIKE SENATOR MAN WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DISCONNECT
OF POTENTIAL CONFLICT BETWEEN
WHERE SERVICES ARE BEING
PROVIDED AND WHERE THE FUNDS
ARE ALLOCATED. WE BELIEVE THE
FUND SHOULD BE RESTRICTED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES BOTH
ARE REQUIRED SERVICES AND WELL
INTERVENTION OUTSIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ARE WISE INVESTMENTS
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED BY
PRESCHOOL SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES. AND THEN FINALLY WE
WOULD SUPPORT ALTHOUGH THE
HIGHER COMPOUNDED COLA FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WHICH ALSO
RECEIVED YOUR CALL AND THE
CURRENT YEAR AND YOU THINK WHAT
THE L. AT THAT SHOULD BE HIGHER
CALL UP THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT SPEAKER.
BARNETT PUBLIC COME WILL COME
NUMBER. SEVEN TWO SO YOUR LINE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING IS SERRA IS
EXPECTED TO FOR T. CAL. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR- FUTURE
FELLOWS ARE TEACHERS FROM
AROUND THE- I WANT MENTION TALK
ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. WE'RE
VERY. OF GOVERNOR SPOKE ON THE
WELL BEING THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR STUDENTS AND THE USE OF
EFFECTIVE USE OF SCHOOL CLIMATE
SURVEYS TO ADVANCE PLAN
PRIORITIZE THAT- WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE INVESTMENT
SUPPORTING THE EDUCATORS ON THE
GROUND TO. USE THOSE SURVEYS TO
IMPROVE. THAT SCHOOL CLIMATE
FOR STUDENTS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT WE BELIEVE THERE
IS- I GAPS. IN AND HOW WE USE
THOSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE TRULY TO
PRIORITIZE WILL CLIMB IN THE
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- IDENTIFYING
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING AND WITHOUT
CONSISTENT DATA ACROSS THE
STATE WERE UNABLE TO DO THAT
AND AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED-
NEARLY THREE QUARTERS OF
DISTRICTS ARE. ARE HAVE ALREADY
ADMINISTERED THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY WE BELIEVE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GATHER STATEWIDE DATA BY-
CREATING A SUBSET OF THAT
SURVEY THAT THAT OLD DISTRICT
ALL ELEAZAR CAN ADMINISTER TO
THAT WE HAVE CONSISTENT DATA
ACROSS THE STATE WE CAN
IDENTIFY. HOLDEN DISTRICTS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING AND GET THEM THE
HELP AND SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH KRISHER COMMENTS.
MISTER MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER.
OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMING WILL
COME FROM MEMBERS ONE LINES ONE
YEAR LINE ITSELF. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAD A
CAREER ON BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ASKED THAT I ALSO
OFFER COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT. EARLY EDUCATION EAGLE
UNIFIED APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO THE
VISION OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EARLY LEARNING CARE WITH THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT TO EXPAND
G. K. ACT OF TWO MORE FOUR YEAR
OLD. CONSISTENT WITH THE L. A.
O. CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ONE TIME INCENTIVE GRANT
PROPOSAL- KILL LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO RECOGNIZE AND
FULLY FUND THE ON GOING COST. A
VOLUNTARY EXPANDED SHE CAME TO
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FOR THE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS BEING SERVED WITH
PROGRAM QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
SUCH AS LOWER CLASS SIZE
RATIOS. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE'S CURRENT REVENUE
LANDSCAPE CAN ACCOMMODATE THESE
COSTS AND CAN GIVE DISTRICTS
THE ONGOING RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO HELP ACHIEVE THE LARGER
VISION OF UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY PRESCHOOL
EXPERIENCES. FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN CALIFORNIA WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. DURING THE
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
OF MR MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER.
OUR NEXT COMING COMES FROM
NUMBER THREE TWO THREE YEAR IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BILL YOU SEE
A PRESIDENT OF THAT VOICE-
INTERJECTED TIED NUMBER ONE. A
LOT COULD CHANGE TO BILL
APPROPRIATES OPENS TODAY PART
REESE GOING FORWARD WHETHER
IT'S MY THOUSAND FOUR FIVE AND
A HALF THOUSAND POSTS THE
LEGISLATURE BE GIVEN SOME DATA
ON HOW MONEY WAS YOU TO HELP
THE TARGET PARKING. WE
SPECIFICALLY CAN WOULD REQUIRE
MADE BY THE CHAIRED BY THE NEED
TO AGREE ON WHAT THE STATE
KNOWS DOESN'T MORE. WITHOUT
CHANCE ON THE- OF FUNDING BY
THIS. THE LEGISLATURE HAS VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION TO ENSURE
THE INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE
ARE LIKELY TO PRODUCE THE HOPED
FOR OUTCOME. A NICE NUMBER
EXAMPLE DISTRICTS WOULD SEEN.
ABOUT USING. THE STATUS. FOR
WORKING WITH YOUNG OF EDUCATION
FOR THIS PROGRAM KID THAT. THEN
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSTANTLY.
THE FUNDING LEVEL. GOING
FORWARD TO ENSURE THEM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER MODERATOR
NEXT TO SPEAKER. YES AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO QUEUE
UP HERE A PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX TO SIX OR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE CARROT CALL WITH NEAREST
CALIFORNIA. WILL FOCUS OUR
COMIC CON ISSUE FIVE SCHOOL
NUTRITION- WE COMMEND NUTRITION
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MEALS TO
STUDENTS UNDER THE MOST
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES
DURING THE ACADEMIC AND AS WE
HEARD. THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE OF
ACCESS MEALS FREE OF CHARGE
FROM SCHOOLS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. BUT WHEN
COLLECTABILITY EXPIRES THEIR
SCHEDULE TO THIS JUNE MANY
FAMILIES WILL FACE A SCHOOL
MEAL CLIP AND LOSE ACCESS TO
THREE MEALS IS A PARTICULARLY
HARM BLACK AND LYFT NEXT
STUDENTS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HIGHER LEVELS OF FOOD
INSECURITY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE NEED TO ENSURE A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION WHEN FEDERAL WAIVERS
EXPIRE SO KIDS AND FAMILIES CAN
REBOUND AND RECOVER. NUMEROUS
HIGH NEED THIS AND TELL. DO
ONE. THE I WANT TO IMPLEMENT.
PRE BUILT ON AN ON GOING TO.
BUT THEY FIND IT WE COUNT. WE
RESPECTFULLY THAT THE STATE
MAKE TARGETED INVESTMENTS TO
ENABLE MANY MORE HIGH NEED
SCHOOLS TO CONTINUE TO OFFER
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FREE OF
CHARGE TO ALL USE. THE
FEDERALLY AUTHORIZED COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY PROVISION. IF WE
ACT THIS YEAR WE CAN ENSURE
KIDS CONTINUE TO GET MILK THEY
NEED AND STABILIZE SCHOOL
NUTRITION BUDGETS DURING AND
AFTER THE COPA CRISIS. THANK
YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION THROUGHOUT
THE BUDGET PROCESS FUTURE
STUDENTS HAVE THE FOOD THEY
NEED. TO LEARN AND SIXTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MODERATOR. BE
EXPLICA FROM SOMEONE NUMBER
THIRTY LINE THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS SURELY THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE TEN
BINDING PRETTY CAN'T WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE FUNDING FOR ADDING A NEW
GRADE WILL BE INSUFFICIENT. I'M
REALLY A NOTED THE FUNDS
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT ANY GREAT
ARE LARGE AND ONGOING AND MUST
BE SUPPORTED WITH ONGOING
FUNDING FOR ALL STUDENTS NOT
JUST THOSE DISTRICTS WITH
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS. AND
CURRENTLY I CURRENTLY APPROACH.
WE ARE ADDITION CONFIRM WITH A
LOT OF THE SO FUNDING. THAT
MANY TRIED TO NOT HAVE. SPACE
FOR ADDITIONAL ASIA PER. HE
CAN'T CLASS. NOR DO THEY HAVE A
FUTURE. AND THE LARGER TO. LOW
BECAUSE- WE URGE LIKE I TO MUCH.
TO BANKS THE COPY IT GUARANTEED
OKAY FOR THIS GREAT NOT TO
LEAVE WHEN THEY EXISTING. IN
THE FORM. AND WE ALSO LIKE TO
LIE ARE. TO THEIR COLLEAGUE HAD
A AT THE RELEASED A THREE EIGHT
OR- COAL. YOUR CHILD AND TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR MODERATE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY LINE ST YEAR LONG
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
MEMBERS THIS IS A PRIMACK WHICH
ARE SCHOOLS CENTER WE SUPPORT
THE L. A. O. RECOMMEND THAT BE.
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL INTO THE
BAY. AND WHILE IT IS TRUE
pOF PRE STUDENTS THEIR- SCHOOL
THIS. WILL ALSO THAT- MANY CHOI
SCHOOL URBAN K. TWELVE RANGE A
MUCH HIGHER PROPORTION SOME OF
MY MEMBERS SERVING DOUBLE THE
NORMAL PROPORTION OF SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS AND RECEIVE.
LESS BOND BANK WHEN DISTRICTS
DO. SERVING HAPPENS MANY
STUDENTS AND SO WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A SINGLE
FUNDING FORMULA AND TO MAKE
THAT FUNDING FORMULA MORE
SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUAL ALLEY A- PARTICULAR
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT SERVE HIGH
PROPORTIONS OF THEM. WITH
RESPECT TO THE T. K. PROPOSAL
WE BELIEVE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FACILITY
FUNDING THEY'VE BEEN DENIED
ACCESS. TO THIS PROGRAM IN
PRIOR YEARS AND- I COULD SEE
THEM BE ABLE TO. BLANK FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR NEXT. YES ANOTHER
LINE NUMBER ELEVEN LINE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH. I'M
ALL RIGHT APPARENTLY THEY HAVE-
RELEASED THEIR LINE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN LINE
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU IN THE MORNING SHE-
I'M NOT- HELLO EVERYONE. I
DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS. ELEVEN
ALL. ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES
GOOD A GOOD MORNING I
UNDERSTAND SOMEONE ELSE SOMEONE
ELSE WAS SPEAKING AS WELL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS IS GERRY
PATEL FROM SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE APPRECIATE
THE SEVENTY FIVE CENTS THAT WAS
GIVEN TO SCHOOL FOR ADDITIONAL.
MONIES FOR MEALS- AS AS A HELP-
DURING THE PANDEMIC WITH
ADDITIONAL- HE QUIT MEANT- A
COULD I OUR COST OF FOOD- AS
MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW SERVING
KIDS WERE ONLY SERVING FORTY TO
SIXTY PERCENT- WITH THE
CONTINUED LABOR COSTS. AND
NUTRITIONAL EQUIPMENT THAT WE
ALL HAD A PURCHASE WE WOULD
APPRECIATE EXTENDING THAT
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS. PER MEDIA
ALL OF FROM SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE JUNE OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE- THAT
WILL HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE MEALS TO STUDENTS- AS
WE HAVE YOU KNOW SEARCH
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE'VE EVER
SERVE YOU FOR APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. WE SPOKE OVER TWELVE
MILLION MEALS ARE NORMALLY AT
THIS TIME YOU'RE GOING TO SERVE
TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY SIX
MILLION MEALS WE APPRECIATE-
ANY FUNDING WHAT THE SEVENTY
FIVE CENTS FOR THE ADDITIONAL
MEALS AS. WE KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA. COST OF IN COSTA OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE. WE HAVE-
IN CAL COMPARED TO OTHERS. LIKE
WE- ARE A LOT LESS WE
APPRECIATE STEP OF THIS OFFENSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT MR MODERATOR A COLORS. WE
WILL TRY TO RETURN TO THE LINE
ELEVEN AND SEE IF THEY
RECTIFIED THEIR SITUATION LINE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN PRATT
I WILL BE ITEM ELEVEN SPECIAL
OCCASION. I HAVE A QUESTION
FROM PETERS THERE I SCHOOL AGE
GOAL AND YOUR FOR SCHOOL DOES.
THANK YOU BYE COMIC I AM NOT TO
SIXTY LOOKING ARE YOU P. AND IN
AND. FOR I'M AT. THE RINK. I
THIRD NIGHT. MORE I WANT EIGHT
THE CLASS. SUPPORT COMMUNITY I
WORE ABOUT. YOUR AND. I WOULD
LIKE. FOLLOWING FOR
CONSIDERATION YOU NEED ONLY.
I'M GOING TO RESTART ACOSTA WAS.
I'M ONE OF PERSON INSTRUCT.
SEARCHES AND. TRANSACTION I WAS
GOALS LEARNING AND SCHOOLS WILL
OPEN FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WERE APPROACH THE TEST
INTO THE TO. THAT WAS WHY.
MISTER MODERATOR IN ELSE. WELL
WE DO NOT ANYONE ELSE CURRENTLY
IN CUBA WILL READ IT IS ONE IN
THE ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE
KEYPAD IN ORDER TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE THAT IS COMING UP PLEASE
ALLOW A MOMENT FOR US TO GIVE
PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE NINE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NUTRITION
ASSOCIATION- I WANT TO. THANK
YOU. SURE LARRY COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO REVIEW THE
ISSUE SURROUNDING ROMS
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AS MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HOLD STATED ON WE
ARE FLEXIBLE ON THE GROUND DAY
ONE IN THE COST- I THEY HAD
BEEN INCLUDE ON IN THE SCOPE
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS BUT STILL
REACH ON THE CODE STATE BANK
COMMITTEE. WHILE WE WOULD ALL
WE WOULD JUST ASK FOR SOME
FUNDING TO HELP THE COSTS
EXAMPLE GLAD THAT NORMALLY
WOULD COST SEVEN DOLLARS A CASE
ARE NOW HUNDRED FORTY DOLLARS A
CASE NOT JUST ONE EXAMPLE THE
ADMISSION REQUIREMENTS THE
TRAVEL- AS TRANSPORTATION GOING
TO THE- WHITE. ON ON FROM HAVE
BEEN A HAS BEEN A ARMED ON
EXPENSE FOR- SIX BUT- ANY TO
MAKE PROVIDE- WILL BE ONE OF
CONCRETE THE- ON HIGHER COLA.
WE WOULD LOVE TO BE REACHED AND
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE-
ON AGGRESSIVE AGAIN ONE THANK.
YOU ON YOUR BACK BUT YOU CAN
FIND TO READ THIS YEAR AND TO
BRING A LOT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COM. THE
MISTER MODERATORS THERE ANY
ELSE KEY UP. WE HAVE BECAUSE
THE CUTEST SIR. I'M SORRY ED
UNDERSTAND WHICH IS. SORRY WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE RIGHT DIED
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR CHOICE
OF WORDS- THEN IT THAT.
CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THAT COMMENTED AND
JUST REMIND THEM THAT IF THEY
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
OR THEY WISH TO EXPAND. ON
THEIR COMMENTS THEY COULD
SUBMIT THEIR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET. AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE- SENATOR JOE ABOVE DO
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEITHER
DO WHY SO THANKS EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
AS WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
AND SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
WILL STAND ADJOURNED.